This is Jocko podcast number
one 10 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
All sciences have principles and rules.
War has none.
The great captains who have
written of it give us none.
Extreme cleverness is required to even
understand them and it is impossible to
base any judgment on their relations of
the historian historians for they only
speak of war as their
imaginations painted.
As for the great captains
who have written of it,
they've attempted rather to be
interesting than instructive.
Since the mechanics of
war is dry and tedious,
books dealing with it have small success
and their merit will not be recognized
except after the passage of time.
Those writing historically
of war have better luck.
They are sought by all the curious
and kept in the all libraries.
That is why we only have a confused
idea of the discipline of the Greeks and
Romans wore is a science covered
with shadows in who's obscurity.
One cannot move within assured
step routine and prejudice.
The natural result of ignorance
or its foundation and support.
Nothing is so disgraceful
as lavishness to custom.
This is both a result of
ignorance and a proof of it.
Chevalier,
full lard supposes all men to be brave
at all times and does not realize that
the courage of the troops
must be reborn daily,
that nothing is so variable.
And that the true skill of a general
consists of knowing how to guarantee it by
his dispositions,
his positions,
and those traits of genius that
characterized great captains.
Perhaps he reserved of this immense disc,
perhaps he reserved discussion of this
immense subject and perhaps also escaped
him. Nevertheless, it is
of all the elements of war,
the one that is most necessary to study
the same troops who if attacking would
have been victorious,
may be inevitable,
invariably defeated in entrenchments.
Few men have accounted for
it in a reasonable manner
for it lies in human hearts
and one should search for it.
There no one has written of this matter,
which is of the most importance,
the most learned,
and the most profound of
the profession of war.
And without a knowledge
of the human heart,
one is dependent upon the favor of
which sometimes is very inconstant.
So those are some opening words from a
book called reveries on war by Marise de
sacs.
This guy's a character Marista sacks.
You do a little research on them.
Did you find out how much of a character
he was? He was a serious character.
There's a couple of things.
Even in that opening right there that I
wasn't sure if I was going to cover this
and I was kind of like going back to
it to see if it was something we should
cover. But I just, when
you get right here,
all sciences have principles and rules.
War has none. That's a true statement.
And it's true that there's, you
know, there's principles of warfare,
but there's no actual rules.
Like you can do whatever you want.
I mean you can say the Geneva Convention,
but then you can just defy it and just,
you know, you can do things that
are completely opposed to it.
So there's no rules.
You should do whatever you want to win.
Now you could lose your respect and you
could act in humane and that might cost
you in the long run. But if wars war,
there's no other thing like that.
Right. There's no other thing
like that. Do whatever you want.
I guess if you had a,
if you had like a street fight with no
weapons and someone going to do whatever
they could to win. Right.
That's the thing. It's, that's
war. It's the same thing.
Yeah. I'm sure. Yeah.
When you deal with like death is kind
of the goal and the consequences at the
same time, like death. That's
the end of the line. So yeah.
Anything goes essentially.
Yeah. Yeah. Nothing else is
like that. Then he says this,
nothing is so disgraceful as slavish
to custom. That's a bold statement to,
I agree. Disgraceful. He calls it,
he talks about these prejudices that
people have, I think you call them,
what do you call them, by biases,
right? Cognitive biases. He talks about,
he doesn't talk about that, but he talks
about them, but this guy was a character.
He lived from 1696 to 1750 he started off
as a German soldier in the army of the
holy Roman Empire,
which was like this bunch of territories
in Europe that were banded together
under that name.
And they were around for a long time,
from like the Middle Ages until
the time of the Napoleonic wars.
So the early 18 hundreds and he served
also served in the imperial army,
which was another kind of army that often
fought alongside the army of the whole
holy Roman Empire.
And if buddy,
but the weird thing is is he finished
his career as the Marshall General of
France.
And so he had kind of,
I guess you could say
kind of switched sides,
but he Rose Rose up through the ranks
because his military career started at the
age of 13
when he fought at the battle of Mal per k.
I think that's how you say it,
which, and that, that, that war,
that battle right there was,
that was between the army of the
holy Roman Empire and France.
So he was on both sides at
certain points of his life.
And I think the whole time he was,
it seems like from what I read about him,
he was always kind of looking
to go up the social structure,
you know,
rate rise up in the social structure
and become more powerful person in the
hierarchy of those times
in the dominance hierarchy.
So yeah, he started fighting
at age 13 which by the way,
that's just so cool. I don't, I'm
sorry if you think I'm a bad person,
but as far as I'm concerned,
if I could have joined the military at 13
I would have been so stoked. Uh, sorry,
everyone that's, that doesn't agree
with that. That's just how I roll.
I'm just telling the truth on that one.
And actually as I look back on my life,
if I could've done that
would've been even better.
I think they should allow
people to join the military.
They should have some like a Youth Corp.
Yeah,
you can go in and just get
after it at a young age,
but they think they think a 13 year old
can't make that decision and the right,
the 13 year old can't make that decision.
So you'd have to have really benevolent
people that were in charge of them in
charge of these troops.
And you also think that an 18 year
old person can make a good decision.
But if that's not true either,
cause you've got 18 people that are
dumber than dirt and make bad decisions
and people are worried that you're going
to get thoughts put into your head.
Yeah, you are. You are. I guess
what if they're good thoughts,
right on. That's not a
bad thing, right? Yeah.
I mean do you have to learn everything
yourself? Is that the way the world works?
You can't have good
ideas put into your head.
You can't get a little bit programmed.
You could get programmed
to be a better human being.
Would you accept that programming?
Yeah, of course. But Hey,
I'm just checking you're over there
looking like I'm a bad person because I'm
trying to brainwash, you know, cause
you're just saying the word better.
Good and better. Like there's this
universal good and better. You know,
there is no, there isn't. I mean there is,
okay, we have Jordan B. Peterson on here.
You can converse that where you could,
you could have a conversation with
him about that. How do you say that?
You don't know that there's universal
good and use universal banks? No, no, no.
I'm saying,
I mean,
we could give dozens of things
right now that we know are good.
I don't know if the child,
is that good or bad for you,
see where I'm going to take something
that doesn't belong to you, good or bad.
But those, there's still basic
and fundamental that you don't,
you don't need a youth corp to,
well,
there's a lot of people out there
that don't get taught that stuff.
And that's true too. But that's
a whole different issue. Okay.
Well I'm just making sure. Yeah.
But if you're, yeah, I know. Well,
you're saying how you're saying
like good ideas and good ideas.
You're talking about your
way specifically, which I
think, no, no, no, I was not.
I would not. And I still even, you know,
I get in trouble for this because
for instance, if people say, oh,
you shouldn't wake up at four 30 in the
morning. And, and I always say like, yeah,
I know. I'm not saying you have to
wake up at four 30 in the morning.
I'm saying to wake up earlier.
Don't be lazy. Yeah. Right.
I'm not saying you have to, I say, you
know, don't eat donuts. Right? Sure.
I'm not saying you can never
taste anything that tastes good. I'm
just saying it'd be smart, man. Come on.
You don't need a donut and
donuts are actually on the eval.
They might just be pure evil too,
by the way. Right. Come on, man.
Don't assume Sony, they don't even
make you feel, I mean, is there any,
do you get any satisfaction
from a donut status? Well,
it depends on what you mean
by satisfaction and you
always want to try and parse
these things. Well, you can't tell
him absolutely. Okay. Of 10 seconds.
Good taste in your mouth. Sugar Rush,
get SOM and technically pay for that.
Health and fitness. You don't
seem to care. No. W who me?
Oh yeah. Nah Man, I care.
I care a lot. Okay. I'm just
making sure I'm trying to,
I'm trying to look at it from all angles,
satisfaction technically and by lucky.
But you could come up with
some fundamental good things
and I'll tell you this,
the military does teach some
fundamental good things.
So if I could have joined at the age
of 13 it would have been good for me.
I would have been stoked.
Actually.
I would have missed out
on some cool stuff too.
Cause I had some fun back in the jury
and I did the stuff that actually led to
me being who I am today. You
know, I learned some stuff
but not what I'm saying.
The point is, is that your
way, not everyone will agree.
I agree with you. Okay. And
I'm sure a bunch of people do,
but I'm just saying
there's like different, no,
I guess I'm not pro universal
brainwashing to mind methods of I'm not,
I'm not, which makes 13 year old by
the way, which a 13 year old now.
I'll tell you, I just said that,
that going in the military,
I would have missed out on some things,
you know,
maybe some growing up experiences.
Uh, Marista sac didn't miss out on a,
on a damn thing cause he was getting
after it in many different ways,
not only on the battlefield but also as a,
a little bit of a maniac.
He was, he, first of all, he was
like apparently a physically,
he was kind of a beast of a man
and like physically and he fought,
he,
he kind of proved himself.
He distinguished themselves in some
big battles as he was 13, 14, 15, 16,
17 years old.
Apparently he could bend a horse
shoe with his hand. And, and I,
I was looking at that, I was thinking
myself. He, they mean hands, right?
They must be enhanced.
It didn't say that it's at
hand and I didn't want to
take anything away from him.
So apparently he could grab,
uh,
he was big and can grab a horseshoe
and just bend it in one hand.
So he had some some serious strength
and through his life he commanded
companies,
which he actually refers to as centuries,
which if you can imagine century,
we know that means a hundred so a
century like the ancient Roman army had
centuries instead of companies and
they weren't even a hundred people.
There were like 80 people,
but he led those,
he led regiments and he led whole armies
and he fought with a lot of success
throughout his career. Now
with that, that being said,
he was far from what anyone would
actually consider a role model because he,
the way he lived his personal life was not
exactly exempt rurally. Exempt, Burley.
I didn't say that word right.
Exam. Blurry. Yes, simpler down. In fact,
all the way he lived his life was
probably the opposite of role model.
So he was forced into marriage at the
age of 18 he didn't want to get married
because he's, I think he was too
much of a womanizer and said,
I don't want to get married,
but he married this heiress 14
year old Eris with a ton of money.
He blew all her money and he was
18 she was 18 she was 14 she was,
she was an error with a bunch of money.
He took all our money and blew it on
horses for his regiment and on women,
Mr Cysts.
And then he had a bunch of public affairs
and everyone kind of knew about it.
And the marriage got an old and he
continued this kind of want and behavior,
I think throughout his life.
And a couple times he's hypocritical
because in the book he talks about certain
types of people.
And I don't know if I cover it,
but he does come across a
little bit hypocritical Buffalo,
hypocritical sometimes.
Now I think one of this is this one
quote I grabbed from this mistress,
this kind of famous mistress actually,
she's recognized as the chief mistress
of King Louis the 15th so did you know
that the king had like not
just mistresses, we know that,
but there's a chief mistress whose known,
her name was Madame de Pompadour and
this is what she said about Saks.
Marista Sachs does not understand
anything about the delicacy of love.
The only pleasure he takes in the society
of women can be summed up in one word,
debauchery.
Okay,
so he's a little bit out of control.
He might have in fact inherited his,
yeah.
Lifestyle choices or from his dad
whose name was Frederick Augustus,
who was well known for his personal,
unbridled lust.
Sure.
How do you know that he had on
bridal lust? Well, case in point,
Maurice was the eldest
son reached to Sachs,
was the eldest of 354 acknowledged
illegitimate children that Frederick
fathered.
So while we might not want to emulate
Marista sacks his personal life,
he was an experienced and successful
leader of men on the battlefield.
And we can learn from him.
And with that,
let's go back to the book
and here's Marista Sachs,
a man who has a talent for
architecture and Ken design.
We'll draw the plan and perspective
of a palace with great skill,
but if he is to execute it,
if he does not know how to shape
his stones to lay his foundation,
the whole edifice will crash soon.
It's the same with the general who does
not know the principles of his art,
nor how to organize his troops for these
are indispensable qualifications in all
the operations of war.
The prodigious success with which the
Romans always gained with small armies
against multitudes of barbarians can be
attributed to nothing but the excellent
composition of their troops.
Not that I would infer from this that
a man of genius will not be able to
succeed even at the head of an
army of tartars. It is much,
this is the,
this is the interesting part.
It is much easier to take men as they
are then to make them as they should be.
It is difficult to reconcile
opinions, prejudice, prejudices,
and passions.
So there's a couple of interesting things.
I also forgot to point
out that he wrote this
kind of on a whim and he actually starts
off this, this whole book kind of,
he says this work was not born from a
desire to establish a new method of the
art award. It was composed
to amuse and instruct myself.
And then one of the last things he
says in the book is to the readers,
I wrote this book in 13 nights.
I was sick.
Thus it very probably
shows the fever I had.
This should supply my excuses for the
irregularity of the arrangement as well as
the inelegance of the style I wrote
militarily to anticipate my boredom.
Now on top of those,
that excuse right on top of that,
he was a big opium user.
So we're figuring he was probably right
in this and an impaired state. Sure.
We're dealing with it. We're not, we're
not mad about it, but we're realistic.
And the reason I say this is because some
of the writing is a little bit tricky
and some run on sentences and yeah,
so we have to,
we have to pull a little bit
harder to get some nuggets,
but there's plenty of nuggets and I think
that's one of them is much easier to
take men as they are then to
make them as they should be.
And where I look at that as a leader,
you get people that are good at something
and you get someone that's not good at
something,
but they're going to something else.
You put people where you can use them.
You put people where their skills are
most available and where they can,
where they can
perform their duties to the highest level
because they're naturally good at it.
That's all it's saying. I'm not having
you proof read my writing at night, right?
Yeah. No, no, no, I'm not,
and I'm not over here trying to
make videos. No, I'm not. Right.
You see where I'm going with us. So it
would it, it'd be easier if you said,
you know what, Jocko, when
it comes to the podcast,
why don't you come up with a talking
a bunch of talking and I'll make cool
videos. Right. We kinda
did that. Otherwise we,
people would be listening to you talking
about movies from 1988 and comparing
them to stuff very, very clunky, which
is, you know, it's fine. Yeah, but,
and then wouldn't you have to expend more
resources and your part to to coach me
up. Yes. So imagine that and, and I'd
be trying to make videos, which I can,
and I'd have to coach you make
me mad. We don't want that. No,
it would make me mad because it's
dealing with computers and stuff.
I don't mind computers, but I
don't like them. Sure. No. So yeah.
Yeah. But that's a, that's a big part of
like why he's saying it though, right?
Because it's like,
it's like you're going to save yourself
a lot of time and headache. Exactly.
But when you're trying to coach
these guys up and when you,
when you get to the seal teams, it's like,
oh, you're a small, a small guy. Cool.
You're going to be appointment.
Yeah. Yeah. You're a big guy. Cool.
You're going to carry it at a and
m 60 or now to mark 48 that's what,
that's how it's happening.
We're not going to take the small guy
and try and get him up him taller and
bigger and stronger and we're not going
to take the big guy and starving and
send them into ranger school. So he loses
38 pounds and he comes back and like,
okay, your appointment now. No,
let's, let's use nature. And he's,
he talks about that in other places.
All right,
he's talking about in
this section how to uh,
how to raise an army basically.
How do you make an army?
And I thought this one was a little bit
interesting because people ask me this
question all the time.
He's talking about mandatory service
and this is his opinion on it.
Would it not be better to
prescribe by law that every man,
whatever his condition in life should
be obliged to serve his prints in his
country for five years? It
doesn't, that's no joke.
Sometimes people say two years and that
seems reasonable and a lot of countries
do that. He says five years,
and it's kind of funny,
his attitude towards five
years back to the book,
this law could not be objected to
because it is natural and just that all
citizens should occupy themselves with
the defense of the nation. Concur.
No inconvenience could result if they
were chosen between the ages of 20 and 30
years.
These are all the years of Libertine Ej.
When youth seeks its fortune,
travels the country,
and is of little comfort to parents.
This would not be a public calamity
because one could be sure that when five
years had passed, discharge would
be granted. So he's saying like,
people couldn't be mad about it cause it's
only five years. And he's also saying,
look, this is when your kids
are out of control anyways.
You might as well have them
in the military. There's that,
that whole idea of the libertine that
took place back in the day and these guys
were, you know, basically wild
morally getting after it or I should.
They were, they were. They were.
They were partying, wicked heart. I'm
trying to think of a good way to say it.
They were pardoned. Wicked hard
with drugs, booze and women. Yeah,
the libertines and they,
that was,
they called them a rake.
Like if a guy,
a guy that was out there with a bunch
of different women all the time,
it'd be called the rakers, a bunch
of period novels that I had to read,
read when I was in college.
That's why I know about it,
about these libertine rakes.
So he continues on.
This method of raising troops would
provide an inexhaustible reservoir of fine
recruits who would not be subject
to desertion in course of time.
As a consequence, it would be regarded as
an honor to have fulfilled one service.
I'd say that's probably accurate,
but to produce this effect is essential.
To make no distinctions, to be immovable
on this point and to enforce the law,
particularly on the nobles and the rich,
then no one will complain,
hey, you gotta if you're
gonna do it to one person,
you got to do it to everyone equally.
Consequently,
those who had not served their time will
scorn those who are reluctant to obey
the law and insensibly.
It will become an honor to serve the poor
bourgeois who will be consoled by the
example of the rich and the wrench will
not dare complain upon seeing the noble
serve arms is an honorable profession.
How many princes have borne arms?
Now what's interesting about this idea
is that there's some people in the world
that aren't really meant for warfare.
And so should we let nature,
I I more, I'm more heavily
agree with the previous point.
You should let people do what
they're good at naturally.
So you're going to end up recruiting
people that might not be good at this
naturally. And that's not a good thing.
But not everyone was aware, right? No,
you're right. You can put them
into different jobs. Yeah, that's,
that's absolutely true. They could
put the, the guy that's more, uh,
more apt to be like good at writing.
He could become a military journalist or
something like that. Yeah, you're right.
You know, people always ask me that
question. And the bottom line is,
it's a tough one.
I'm sure I don't have like a,
some hardcore stance on it one
way or the other. We'll do.
I think it would benefit
everyone every 18 year old,
if they join the military,
it would benefit them.
I'm telling you it would benefit them.
Do I think it should be mandatory?
I don't really think so because I don't
want to have a bunch of draftees in the
military and if you don't want to join
and you want to miss out on having that
part in your life, that's your call
and that's fine. This is America.
You can do what you want.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Cause on one on one hand you kind of
can look at it as like taxes, right?
Where, how it led. Just like
Kyle was saying. Um, you know,
you have to have the
paraphrasing, the, the,
the pleasure of the honor to serve in
once your country's defendant. You know,
like that,
that should be obvious.
And so it's Kinda like couldn't
compare it with paying taxes. Right?
Taxes go to public service for all this
stuff. And we live in this country.
We have public service, we all have
to pay for it, not just one person.
When we all pay tax, a lot of people
pay a lot more than other people. Yeah,
exactly right. And not more. Yeah, and
some people don't really pay taxes.
You just said everyone pays their taxes
and not everyone pays. I know that.
And if so, what if it was all
good? Yeah, perfect. Exactly.
Part of my point is, so let's say
I'm like, Hey, you just paid you to,
let's say it's tax time,
April 15th whatever. Some
people pay taxes year round,
just FYI. Yeah, no, I'm just saying.
But at the time were called the quarterly
[inaudible]. You don't want none.
I actually know about that now. Thankfully
weren't nuts to think thing. Oh,
but you know,
let's just say for this example it 15
that's when everyone knows it's all right.
And you're like, yeah, I just
paid my taxes, you know, whatever.
Like I didn't like giving my money
away, but that's it. You know,
just like people in the draft situation
or military, military, military,
I didn't want to, I would rather
go be a a rake or whatever and,
but I'm doing it and boom, I did it.
And then you got me, or maybe not me,
someone else saying, Oh yeah, I didn't
pay my taxes. And then you're like, whoa,
wait, wait. You're saying it becomes
an honor to pay your taxes? You know?
Wish I could agree with
you. No, no, no. There's,
I think there's a part of your brain,
no matter how much you paid for Texas,
it is like you do have that
feeling like, yeah, I did my part.
Even though it sucked, even though
it hurt, even though, you know,
I would way rather have spent it on a
Disney vacation or something like that,
like I'm a citizen from
something that was productive,
generate more business or
something like that, you know?
Just little things like that,
but whatever. You see what
I'm saying? No. All right.
I mean, I hear you. It's
kind of the same thing.
That's one way to look at it though, where
you can, but the other one way. Yeah.
Yeah.
But the other way is just like you said,
if you get some people who were in there
in the military was certain like jobs
or whatever, and they don't want
to be there. It's Kinda like,
it's Kinda too important to have people
like that. But you could have, yeah,
what you said is actually correct
that you could have, you know,
elements that just did other things in
the military that d would be more aligned
with a person's natural desires
of what they want to do. Yeah.
And now there's something in the
navy called needs of the navy. Right.
So you would get the navy, you, oh,
I want to go get stationed
in Hawaii. Like, okay, what
are the needs of the navy?
Because the needs of the navy come first,
not you, not your family. Nothing. Yeah.
And, and so the needs and they would
come first. Well, yeah. And of course,
same thing with like a tax
situation where it's like you're,
if you don't want to do it,
it's kind of hard to be like,
I know you don't want to do it, but hey,
now that you're here, do what you want.
You know, you Kinda can't say
that. Otherwise I'll be like,
I don't want to be here so I
can choose what I can do. Okay.
I'm going to do the the most smallest,
most late, least time consuming.
Like basically I'm gonna do this the
least I possibly can because I don't want
to be here to be in the military.
This is the vault,
this is the mandatory military.
This'll go and that'll go for it.
So you're going to get,
it's kind of like get people that
would be not doing very much. Yeah,
it's essentially like a draft dodger
kind of situation. But within,
you know,
who didn't actually dage it if it,
I'm just saying if it were a scenario,
like we'll just put them where their
interests lie even though they have to be
here. Yeah. See what I'm saying.
So I'm just saying that's the other
side of the coin where it's like, yeah,
it's hard to make, make it work
in an absolute kind of way. Check.
All right. He talked a little bit about
clothing troops, what they should wear,
and this is just,
I thought this was interesting.
Our uniform is not only expensive
but very, very uncomfortable.
The soldiers neither shod nor clothed
nor covered the love of appearance
prevails over attention to health.
And this is one of the most important
points demanding our attention.
Hair is a dirty ornament for a soldier
in once the rainy season has arrived,
has had,
is never dry.
So it sounds to me like he's basically
saying he doesn't care how he looks,
he's healing to win.
They get,
so hair is a dirty ornament
for a soldier in place of hats.
I should prefer helmets. As for
shoes, this was interesting. You know,
people were minimalistic shoes with out.
We'd zero heel to toe drop
if you heard that expression.
No meaning it's the same level across.
So it's any of the barefoot type shoes.
They all say,
Oh zero heel to toe drop.
Meaning there's not an eight millimeter
difference between the height of the
heel and then it goes down to the
height of the toe. This is what he says.
As for shoes,
I would prefer the soldiers to have shoes
of thin level leather with low heels
instead of heavy boots.
They would be perfectly shod,
would and would march with better grace.
Since low heels would force
them to turn out their toes,
stretch their joints,
and consequently consequently
draw in their shoulders.
It's pretty interesting because everyone's
all in the rage of minimalistic shoes,
which I actually wear shoes that
don't have any heel toe drop.
Maybe I'm caught up in that fad,
but it's cool. But you know what?
When we were kids, right?
Chuck Taylors? Yeah. Yeah.
They have no heel toe drop people
so wearing cause they're good to go.
That's kind of all right. Well we'll
fill only way I know. Well there you go.
You're the big time trend.
You're, you're a early adopter.
Yeah. Again, I didn't know about,
I probably chuck Taylor's a too
narrow for me to narrow. Yeah,
and they don't sell wide
ones. I've looked all right.
Pay What you got to pay
people back to the book.
Without going into detail about
the different rates of pay,
I shall only say that it should be ample.
It is better to have a small number of
well kept and well disciplined troops
than to have a great number who
are neglected in these matters.
It is not the big armies that win battles.
It is the good ones.
Economy can boost p pushed
only to a certain point.
It has limits beyond which
it degenerate into parsimony.
I had to look that word up by
the way. Parsa Motors. Yeah.
Occasionally you get one of those.
It means just super cheap.
Super cheap.
That's interesting because that doesn't
sound like that Dabney would fall in
that category.
Parthenon.
If your dad would be considered
parsimonious, I guess so. I know that my,
my dad liked many dads will
drive an extra 18 miles to save
3 cents a gallon on gas. Is that,
is it all bad to do that? No,
I don't know why they don't do that.
Well, yeah, you drive 18 miles. You're,
you're in the ocean most of the time.
But yeah,
I've heard of that before.
Isn't that like a false thing though?
Like cause he just kept driving drunk for
sure. It's kind of pointless. You know,
you get the APP that has the
cheapest gas prices in your area.
How much time are you spending looking
at an APP that you paid $3 for to find
out whether you can save 2 cents a gallon
on gas. Now I get it, man. I'm cheap.
I inherited that. Right. I
don't like to spend money.
It's hard for me to part with
the, with the money, right.
Including the tax man by the
way. It's offered. So I get it.
But I also have to have some,
like sometimes my dad could be
irrational about irrational.
Just straight up crazy. Hey Wall,
you could save 2 cents. Yeah. Hey,
if you know I, he gets fired up about
that too. That's another thing, you know,
he always asks me how much the,
how much the gas out there in California.
I'm like, I didn't know
my pay for it. Anyways,
we'll stick the nozzle in there and
pull the trigger and rock and roll.
I got stuff I gotta do.
I'm not driving.
How much cheaper is gas on base when I
didn't know how much cheaper gas was on
base, he was beside himself and then
we found out it was 8 cents a gallon.
Cheaper all and keep you on.
Basically you want to go drive over there,
wait in line, show you right knee and
then we get on base. You got to wait.
Cause know. Yeah, come on. Wait,
isn't there because parsimonious.
Parsimonious. Yeah. Huh. I'm gonna try
it. Use Ellen. But that's because the,
because it's like a, it's
like a win, right? You get
a win when you got the deal.
You think you've got the psychological
when, yeah, yeah. No, that's,
that's definitely, that could
be it. A little victory.
Yeah. I think because yeah,
people like that too.
Back to the book.
Hope encourages men to endure and attempt
everything in depriving them of it or
in making it to distance.
You deprive them of their very soul.
Now,
that immediately made me think of Stalin
Grad when we were reading about stolen
rod and the fact that the soldiers,
when something would give
him a glimmer of hope,
it would totally change their attitude
when they thought that the German troops
were coming to rescue the guys that were
installing Grad in the pocket and solid
rock, they are all excited and they
were happy and he literally said like,
everyone's morale went up and then
they find out they're not coming in.
Just crushed, crushed to morale. Yeah.
We think that's based on hope fully.
And that you kind of see that in like
in like like a workout for example.
Like if you have a, in football we,
we'd have like conditioning, right?
And sometimes they'd just be like, hey,
we're just running sprints, wind sprints.
They wouldn't say, Hey, we've got 10
wins for instance, is not like that.
And after a while, like guys are dying
and you know, not dying, but you know,
we're getting tired. So the sprints
are a lot slower towards it,
but they say two more
finish hard for all of a sudden
everybody can run fast again.
You know what I'm saying?
Even though,
cause you see that little light thing
and tone at seconds. Pretty cool.
I was kidding.
But I do it.
And then you watch the hope.
Just go back to being slow
back to the book. This is,
this is pretty heavy. Truly.
The only good officers are the poor
gentleman who have nothing but their sword
and their cape.
But it is essential that they
should be able to live on their pay.
The man who devotes himself to war should
regard it as a religious order into
which he enters.
He should have nothing,
no other home than his troop and should
hold himself honored in his profession.
So there you go. All in, all in.
And when people always ask me,
especially when I was in about work
life balance and I'm like, Hey,
oh I'm not the guy to talk
about not the good person,
especially when I was in the military
because this was me. You know,
my number one priority hundred percent
was the dames and everything else was
just kind of, hey, you're everyone
else's along for the ride.
But I know where I'm going.
So the being that devoted to war and
it has a power that has a certain,
it made, you know, if you've got a guy
that's thinking about all the time,
I think it was jade, jade and I were
talking about something and he said,
the person who cares more wins.
Yeah, that's, that's accurate.
And I want a lot of stuff in my day
just because I cared more. I mean,
I'm not going to sleep. I'm not, I'm
just going to be thinking about this.
You're going to go home and this weekend
you're going to go and do a family
barbecue and you're going
to go play baseball with the
kids and blah, blah, blah.
And I was just like, no, I'm just
going to be doing this all weekend.
I'm going to be working on this.
We're going to win. I'm, I got, um,
I care about this. Nothing
else matters. So that's, uh,
again, is it healthy for
work life balance? No,
it's not healthy except for to say,
if you're that committed to your work,
you're a committed person,
then that means you're trying
to take care of your family.
That's not necessarily a bad
thing. Am I reaching maybe? Yeah,
I think I'm reaching.
That's fine. You know,
Marissa,
a good independent woman that doesn't
need emotional support from you all the
time, so that she understands that.
That was the big thing for me.
I think my wife understood that it
wasn't meant as an offensive thing.
Yeah.
I have a job and I
really care about my job.
Doesn't mean I don't care about you,
but my job is right now and
I need to do that. Yeah,
and even the work life balance. My
just a bad husband. No, no, because no,
because there is no
templated time allotted.
You know that you need to spend with
these people or those people are at work
versus fat. There's no like thing. You
know, sometimes if you're like, hey,
I need to spend more time with
my wife. Your wife's like, Bro,
go do leave me alone. You know? Like we,
we spent the weekend again, calm down,
you know, go to work or whatever. Some
people like that and it's a spectrum.
So work life balance is like,
it depends on your wife and you know,
in a husband wife situation I suppose
instead of instead of trying to take a
life work life balance lesson out of this,
I think the most important
thing to take out of this is,
is the level of commitment,
right?
If you really want to be successful
and not just talking about Warren,
I'm talking about business,
I'm talking about life.
If you really want to be successful, you
got to, you got to get after it. Yeah.
And you see this set the other things
aside for now, just the way it is. Yeah.
Yeah. Sorry. All right. Back to the book.
Training drill is necessary to make
the soldier steady and skillful,
although it does not warrant exclusive
attention among all the elements of war
is it even is the one
that deserves the least.
If one accepts those which are dangerous,
I tried to figure out what that meant.
I just thought opium.
That was an opium hit right there.
The last part,
the foundation of training depends. Oh,
this is good but, but okay, so drill.
If you know anything about the military
drill, especially back in those days,
it was a really was a necessary thing
because you had to function together as a
team and the way you do that,
and we still do what's called close order
drill in the military now you've seen
it go watch the US Marine Corps
close order, silent drill team.
They do all these really
specific maneuvers and they
have competitions in high
schools between the ROTC classes where
you know you're carrying the rifle,
you spin, you do that, all that
stuff. That's called drill. Yeah.
The reason it originated is because you
needed to for two reasons. Number one,
you actually had to do those motions
on the battlefield, raise your rifle,
you know, load, remake, ready, aim, fire,
and then the next rank will be doing
the same thing you had to do in a
coordinated method. And the other
reason that they kept doing it,
according to my drill instructor
in officer candidate school,
Gunnery Sergeant United States Marine
Corps, all the enough last name was seals.
That was his last name. Great Guy.
Yeah, layers, gunnery sergeant seals,
my drum instructor
from the United States Marine Corps
at officer candidate school. He said,
the reason that you're learning this
drill is because the reason that we do
drill is it because people need
to act instantly upon orders.
So it,
it drills into you a level of obedience
when you get told by the left flank
march, everyone goes by the right
flank, March, everyone goes, you know,
so it teaches you that hey,
I'm going to go.
And that's what they used to use it for.
But they still use it now too.
So that people get used to the
immediate obedience of orders.
Now does that get contradicted by things
that I talk about all the time on here,
but questioning orders and making sure
you understand why you're doing. Yeah,
it does. Absolutely. But
there is a, that's why. That's
what it exists for. Yeah.
Yeah. And at least the capabilities
and the capability is there. Yes,
the capability is there.
Back to the book,
the foundation of training depends
on the legs and not the arms.
All the mystery of maneuvers and combat
is in the legs and it is to the legs
that we should apply ourselves,
whoever claims otherwise is but a fool
and not only in the elements of what is
called the profession of arms.
So interestingly your personal problem
with people that talk about skipping leg
day, the, it goes back,
it goes back to here.
The big guns, the big arms, they didn't
want to help us in the, in the art of war,
according to Zach's in Hawaii
they call it big for nothing,
actually big for nothing in Hawaiian
means like I guess here they say all go no
shell.
Right.
So that's kind of what having big arms
and small legs kind of is as well.
Right through. Now you're on
board with that. Well yeah.
No I never was skipping legs day.
You're the one teasing me
and I was wondering why is
that so funny? But I guess,
yeah, that that's fine.
Cause you look like a fool.
That's it. That's the answer. Dang it
goes back. It was back a long time.
Even back then people were skipping
leg day. Yeah cause they were fools.
I'm focusing on the wrong thing and it
makes sense. Even like in those terms,
it makes sense today.
Let me tell you something.
The the amount we can,
when I was in the team,
so I was running training and
I still talked guys obviously,
but if you think about what's going
on the train like people to people,
you know, I say all the time, like all
of the seal training is not that hard.
Right? I say old time, like
when I'm talking about buds,
I'm telling you the advanced
training that you go to,
the training that I used to run it,
it's, it's freaking really hard.
It's really hard. You're in the desert.
The desert. No, don't think of sand.
Think of rocks. Think of jagged,
uneven terrain up and down hills.
Then think about you're on night vision,
so it's at night. Think about, you have,
let's call it about 80 pounds
of gear on just on average.
That's like the average guy's
got 80 pounds of gear on.
You're going to get dropped off in
the middle of the desert. Again,
not the desert, but the
rocky, what's it called? Sub?
I forget. It's, it's
the rocky crazy terrain.
It's hard to walk on in the daytime.
It's hard to walk on.
Now you're at the yard at night. Now you
have night vision on, which is great,
but my vision is looking far away and
you can adjust one of your night vision
side. So you have to, and you can
adjust one to foreign, one to close,
so you can see a little bit, but still
your peripheral vision isn't there.
Your peripheral vision is gone because
there's a tube in front of your head,
so you can't really see what's
actually underneath your feet.
You can look down and then
you can see it for a second,
but you can't walk around
looking down the whole time.
You got to look the guy in front of
you got to look at your field of fire.
So as you're walking, you're making
these micro adjustments all the time,
adapt to your foot,
hitting the ground in some weird spot.
And so you get that and then you have
that weight on your back and so you get
dropped off. Then you patrol 10
kilometers, 10 kilometers maybe.
What's that? That's six miles.
So, so you're going six miles,
then you get six miles. You get to a
target area, you get to the target area.
You got to get eyes on the target area.
You know you'd get eyes on,
you climbed the biggest halo round
at night, being as quiet as you can.
You get to the top of that hill,
you look at it,
then you go and assault the target.
Once you assault the target,
guess what you're going for?
When you're and the target you
are now like almost running.
You're running through the thing at night.
You're shooting machine guns.
Guess what, guys? Get hit. Guys
go down. This. Even in training,
guys are going down now you're
going to carry him. Well,
who are you going to carry him?
Who's gonna carry him? You are.
What are you going to do? How are you
going to carry him? You're going to,
there's only one way. Sure. Okay.
There's stretchers. There's you can be,
you can bring litters and we
certainly bring litters in the field,
but they take some time to set up and
you've got to get organized to make that
happen.
What's going to happen
initially is somebody is going
to sling that dude on his
back.
And by the way,
that person that weighs 200 pounds
has 80 pounds of gear with them.
So now we're talking 280 pounds.
You're going to put that person on your
back and you're going to walk at a high
rate of speed through this rocky terrain
and you're going to do that for another
two to three miles to get out.
It's hard.
That kind of training, and by the way,
this whole time there's no like who are,
there's no, hey, come on. There's
no, there's no, there's no,
you don't even speak it just in silence
and just going and everyone knows what
you have to do.
And so that's why you got to do leg day,
not skip leg day because your legs, your
legs got to carry that weight. Yeah.
Going back to the book to return to
the march about which everyone bothers
themselves to the death.
But we'll never reach a conclusion
unless I reveal a secret.
So he's got a secret about
maneuvering troops. This is this,
I found this interesting, some wish to
march slowly, others would march fast.
But what about the troops whom no one
knows how to make march fast or slowly as
the desire or as necessary and who
require an officer at every corner to make
them turn like some snails
and others are running.
And this is to advance this column,
which is always trailing.
It is a common unit to see even
a battalion to commence movement.
So what he's talking about,
if you're moving with a unit,
and this happens with even
happens with a platoon,
but it definitely happens when
you get bigger elements, you know,
a company sized element where you've
got a hundred people that are moving,
it's, it's uh, the caterpillar
effect, right? Like the front moves.
And then it takes a little
while for people to catch
up and then when they stop,
everyone bumps into him and you end
up with this just thing that's really,
really hard to move. Yeah, and this is so,
this is how he says,
this is his big secret,
shall I say it,
this great word which comprises all
the mystery of the art and which,
which will no doubt be seen as ridiculous,
have them march in cadence.
That is why these musical marches were
instituted and that is why one beats the
drum.
It is this which no one knows and
no one has perceived with this.
You can march fast or slow as you wish.
The tail will not lose the distance.
All your soldiers will
start on the same foot.
The changes of direction will be made
together with speed and grace and the legs
of your soldiers will not get tangled up.
You will not be forced to halt after each
turn in order to start off on the same
foot.
Your soldiers will not exhaust themselves
at quarter as much as that presence.
Now, what I thought was interesting about
that is it's an obvious answer, right?
And now,
clearly you're not going to do that in
the modern day military in the field.
You're not going to play music.
So guys could march to it
so you can stay in Caden's.
But I think it's more important to that.
Sometimes we lose things,
we lose methods who they're
in front of our face,
but we don't understand why they were
there. And I'll say, I'll tell you,
I was thinking of a story.
I was running training and
one of my guys who was,
uh,
one of the assistant platoon commanders,
Entu bruiser great guy. Hard
to choke, real long neck,
you know, you can make it happen.
You're going to work for it real.
Is it some people you might think long
neck, easy to choke, right? Yeah, no,
this was, his neck was so
long and he was strong too.
He is dark long and strong Max.
So his neck would like band and the gaiety
keep breathing. Yeah, it was that long.
It was a long neck.
So anyways,
we were out at this training site
and we were doing, he was his,
it was his platoon now he was a platoon
commander and they were coming over the
beach and meaning swimming over the beach
and then you go do live fire and this
really, so, so they're doing it,
they're doing iterations and he's
coming up on the beach and is a weapons,
you know, you, you, when you get to
the beach, your weapons Wet Sandy,
cause you go through the surf and it's
all jacked up and then you try and shoot
your gun and it doesn't work. You've
got to clean it and it's just a pain.
And he says,
Hey man,
do you have any like suggestions on how
to get my weapon firing once I get over
the beach? And I go, yeah
man, don't let it get wet.
And he was kind of, you know, like really?
And I said, yeah, don't let it get wet.
Because when you're swimming in, you've
got a rucksack. But the rucksack isn't,
it's, it's waterproofed.
So it kind of floats.
And so you can put your weapon on top of
your rucksack and you can kind of keep
it try there. And when you're
just swimming, you just keep it.
Now you're not going to keep
your weapon completely dry.
It's not going to happen. It's
going to get wet. But the attitude,
if you have the attitude that
you're trying to keep it dry,
you'll keep it 90% more dry
than you would otherwise.
And most important when
you come through the beach,
when you come through the waves,
you won't let it get the sand in it.
And he kind of looked at me with a
funny face of like, are you seriously?
How can you keep it dry?
And I said, keep it dry.
Next time I'm watching
him or on night vision,
I'm watching him and sure enough way is
his weapon barely went in the water and
he got up on the beach and boom, it works.
Guess what? That's an obvious answer,
but sometimes people,
we know we just need to have somebody
share the obvious answer with us so that
we can execute. Yeah,
no, that makes sense.
The thing is that day.
And that's crazy.
I didn't know that that marching thing
like that's why he marched the cadence
that caterpillar affects shuts down.
Why there's traffic by the way,
traffic exists because of that
little effect. That's exactly true.
You know one guy,
one guy going and the reaction time and
the other funny thing he said in here is
he says,
go watch people dance.
You see a soldier dance all night but
he can't march for more than an hour
without being tired. Why is that?
Give him some music. Kind of funny.
I didn't want to say that part cause then
people started asking me about dancing
today. Then we'll see you Dan. No,
no talk of dance on the podcast.
Back to the book.
If the previous war had lasted
a little longer in do boobly,
everyone would've fought a hand to hand.
This was because the abusive
firing began to be appreciated.
It causes more noise than harm and those
who depend on it are always beaten.
So what do you mean?
I can encapsulate a lot of stuff?
What he was talking about was how everyone
was so excited to shoot their rifles.
And at this time period,
the rifles weren't all that accurate.
And so it was a bunch of noise,
but they weren't always that effective.
And it would be better. And
by the way, when you, when
you had to shoot your rifle,
you had to stop. So now instead of
charging, we're stopping, we're loading,
we're firing, the other rank is firing.
And if the other people are moving on you,
well they're going to get close enough
and they're going to have no now momentum
and they're going to overtake you or
they're going to overpower you with what?
With bayonets and hand to hand combat.
So what I thought was interesting
about this is he saying, hey,
all this noise,
it's basically noisemakers
for PR for all practical purposes.
Their noisemakers and he's saying,
and what I was thinking
was, it's, this goes to be,
this to me is very similar to people
that yell a lot, right? You yell a lot,
you are someone that's loud,
someone that's always talking to him.
And he says that people who
depended on that are always beaten.
And I thought to myself,
that's a very accurate statement.
Very accurate statement.
So don't just talk for the
purpose of talking, right?
Don't. If you don't have anything to say,
that's fine. Be Quiet. Don't say anything.
It's actually good
here.
He talks about the Roman legions.
The Romans vanquished all
nations by their discipline.
Okay,
no big deal.
No,
they meditated on war constantly,
continually,
and they always renounced old
costumes whenever they found better.
In this respect,
they differed from the Gauls whom they
defeated during several centuries without
the ladder thinking of
correcting their errors.
So this is clearly the Romans. Okay?
We know discipline's important.
Talk about it all the time.
But more important lesson here is they
always renounced old costumes whenever
they found better.
Boom.
Hmm.
Renounced the old customs.
When you find better ones,
this is something you
need to do in your life.
It's something that needs
you and your business.
It's something you needed
to do on the mat. Okay?
And I'll tell you,
going back to the other part,
sometimes there's things in Jujitsu that
you find a better way and they work for
awhile and then you go back to the old
way and it works because people are
expecting the new way the dean talks to
you and say this is a new old move. Yeah,
yeah. He just said that the end
of the day is a new old move. It,
it worked 10 years ago. It wouldn't work
five years ago because everyone knew it.
Now it'll work again cause
everyone forgot it. Yeah.
And that's kind of like everyone forgot
why, why we use cadence, why we use music.
Yeah. We forgot why. We don't
know how to March now. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
and it's essentially the same reason why
the new move will work because people
are unfamiliar, you know, cause you know,
you have a certain attack or whatever
and then the more people know about that
attack, the harder it is to,
to be successful with it.
And then you find some new variation
then that not everyone knows.
The football game kind of was like
that too, for a little bit. Uh,
and then after awhile,
all those fundamentals which work
essentially the early version of the,
of the move. Yeah. Whatever.
That's still there.
But we've got this new unrevealed move
that's getting everyone because they're
unfamiliar. It's like us, a surprise
kind of where they're just unfamiliar.
And then now everyone gets familiar with
it and it's like, cool. It was okay. Move.
Yeah. But the real good one was that
original though. Do you want yeah,
but everyone just got you
do it. Yeah. And then once
everyone gets used to the new one,
they'll forget about the old
one. Yeah, for sure. Correct.
And improve.
Renounce your old customers
whenever you find better.
Now he talking a little
bit about peace time
and how you maintain your army during
peace time. He says, as for the cavalry,
it should never be touched,
meaning you shouldn't,
you shouldn't get rid
of any cavalry people.
The old troopers and the
old horses are the good,
and the recruits of either
are absolutely useless.
It is a burden and it is it an expense,
but as indispensable in
regard to the infantry.
As long as there are a few old heads
you can do what you want with the tails.
So a horseman is you got the skilled
horse and you've got the skilled horse
rider and he says in this,
I dunno if I'll read it,
but then he says he also in here it
takes 10 years to make a good a good
cavalryman good guide. It's really good
on the horse with a really good horse,
takes 10 years to make them.
So you can't just get rid of that person.
But an infantry man, if you've got some
good, this is what I liked about it.
If you've got good leadership, good
leadership with infantry men, hey man,
there's some fundamental skills
you're gonna need to learn.
It will be ready to rock and
roll, which is, which is awesome.
Good leadership goes a long way. I
mean, and again, you have to have,
it takes a lot.
It takes the same amount of time to make
a good at infantry leader because those
are skills that take a long time to
develop to become a leader of infantry
troops. But your basic combat rifleman,
you can make them pretty quick,
not like it's all,
it's a hell of a lot easier than
making someone that can ride a horse.
So, and then your leadership's
gonna go a long way
back to the book.
In attacking infantry,
the two rear ranks are to lower
their pikes in this position,
the pikes will extend from six to
seven feet ahead of the front rank.
The front ranks being sheltered in such
a manner will I am sure aim with more
confidence than if they had nothing
in front of them. Besides this,
the third rank can ward off
blows and defend the first rank,
which we'll do,
which it will do much better since
it is covered by the first two ranks.
The second rank,
which is armed with muskets,
can fire and defend the man in
front of him in the first rank.
Without the ladder being obliged to stoop.
This avoids a serious disadvantage which
has incurred in kneeling a dangerous
movement because men who are
afraid prefer this position,
they cannot be made to get up when
wanted and is always necessary to halt,
to kneel according to my formation.
All the men are covered each by each
other with reciprocal confidence.
The front presents a forest of spears
that are parents is formidable and gives
confidence to your own troops
because they feel its power.
So a couple of interesting things there.
Obviously it's a cover moves
situation and, and, and
we're going to work that out.
But I thought beyond that,
it was interesting that if you've got,
if you're going to take a knee, well
there's two things that are happening.
Number one, you have to stop to take a
knee. We're not advancing on our knees.
And number two people that are afraid
they want to be down there and it can be
hard to get them back up.
So don't even let them get down there,
keep that momentum going.
We're looking to keep that momentum going
back to the book,
those who imagine that,
and I think I stayed this every time,
usually around this point in the podcast,
I'm skipping a lot of the book. Sure.
It's just the way it is. We're not
going to read the whole book on here.
You have to order it yourself.
If you want to hear every secret of sacks,
those who imagined that the Roman legions
were composed of Romans from Rome are
very much deceived. They came
from all the nations in the world,
but their composition,
their discipline,
and their methods of fighting or
better than all those other nations.
This is why they conquered them all.
Neither were they conquered in their
turn on until this discipline had to
generated among the Romans.
Discipline.
We'll get you a long way and lack
of discipline will get you killed.
Disintegrated. It disintegrated.
Talking more about cavalry here.
The cavalry should be active and
mounted on horses in nerd to fatigue.
It should be encumbered with as little
baggage as possible and above all should
not make the common error
of having fat horses.
Yeah.
If they could see an enemy every day,
it would only be better for this.
Would soon put them in
condition to attempt anything.
Yeah.
It is certain that the power of power
of cavalry is not understood. Why?
Because of we have love for fat horses.
I had a regimen of German cavalry in
Poland with which I marched more than 1500
leagues in 18 months.
I maintain that this regiment was more
fit for service at the end of this time
than another supplied with fat horses.
But to reach this condition,
they must be gradually accustomed to
hardship and hardened by Hans and violent
exercise.
This will maintain their health and
increase their endurance. Likewise,
it will make cavalry men of the troopers
and give them a Marshall bearing.
So you got to train hard. Hmm.
I just read all that to basically say,
you got to train hard.
Even want to be ready to fight.
You've got to trade how your fight
and don't get on a fat a horse.
Apparently.
We'll have to ask my wife about that one.
She knows more about horses than me
or Lafe. Lafe knows about horses.
He's from Texas. Everyone from Texas
rides a horse. Yeah. Is that the image?
Yes. When I go, when I would go overseas,
people for everyone in America is
basically carrying a pistol on him at all
times. That's, that's the, that's the
image that people have of America.
I liked that image for people
to have America too. I mean,
I'm sure some people don't like
that image, but yeah. You know,
be nice when you come here, you can
want to come and visit. That's cool.
We welcome visitors.
Just be nice. Everyone's,
everyone's carrying a
45 in their back pocket.
Yeah.
Can you carry a 45 in your back pocket?
You could. I mean, would it recommended no
one recommended you get a holster? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, but it's more
of an expression. No, no.
It's not even an expression,
but if you go to another country,
they think that we've just
got them in our back pocket.
Like you carry your wallet and a 45 yeah.
What?
You see where I'm coming from here?
Yes. Is how we roll Miz America.
Okay.
I do not.
Back to the book.
I do not know why armor has been laid
aside for the for nothing is either so
useful or ornamental.
If it be considered,
how many troopers perish by the
sword and how many are are? How many?
Many are dangerously wounded
by random and weak shots.
Accident accidents against which
armor guarantees protection.
One cannot avoid acknowledging
the benefits of it.
It is nothing but indolence and relaxation
of discipline that caused it to be
laid aside.
It is worrisome to carry a queer ass and
I'll trail pike and trail a pike half a
century to use it a single day,
but as soon as disciplined
as neglected in the nation.
As soon as comfort becomes an aim,
it needs no inspiration to foretell.
That ruin is near
the Romans conquered all peoples by
their discipline in the measure that it
became corrupted,
their success decreased when the emperor
Gracian permitted the legions to quit
their cure asses and helmets because the
soldiers complain they were too heavy.
All was lost.
The ball bearings whom they had defeated
during so many centuries vanquish them.
Well, that's all. That's all.
People stop wearing their armor because
it's heavy. Body armor is heavy.
Yeah.
Helmet your helmets heavy. Yeah.
You want that? A little tiny helmet.
You want the whole, the take out the
back plate of our body armor. Oh,
probably won't get shot
there. No. Yeah. Was it,
who was taught was that Jody thought
talking about that like, oh my God. Yeah.
Though those guys going into that, they
will, they were going into an operation.
They didn't wear their body armor.
Yeah. Cause they were like, Dang it,
we're not going to happen. Oh, pasta we
plus we w we light and maneuverable. Hmm.
That's the thing you say. Yeah. Yeah. It's
like skipping your workout and saying,
well I need to rest it. Like recovery
today. Yeah. Kind of the same thing.
Very similar. Yes. I'll give
you that one where I go. Yeah.
He obviously,
um,
as soon as discipline is
neglected in a nation,
guess what's the same thing with
your personal life? Obviously
back to the book or the trooper should
have a goatskin bottle like those used in
hot countries instead of a canteen
or a barrel to hold liquors in.
Traded this with his linen stockings,
cap a cord and a other necessities is
to be putting the bottom of a sack which
will roll up with his coat and can be
fastened with two straps behind him.
This will reduce the monstrous load
which has now carried by the cavalry.
It is necessary from time to time to
inspect the baggage and forced the men to
throw away useless items.
I have frequently donut one can hardly
imagine all the trash they carry with
them year after year.
The poor horse has to carry everything.
It is no exaggeration to say that I have
filled 20 wagons with useless rubbish,
which I have found in the
review of a single regimen.
So people will tend to carry a lot,
a lot that they don't need.
And that weighs down on you.
I think I've talked about this before,
but the backend broken to do.
We had these winter paltunes
tunes, which I never did one, uh,
out on the east coast,
they had these winter platoons and you're
going long distance on cross country
skis. Right. You know what
those are? Yeah. It long,
long distances and that is a very,
you're basically like running a marathon.
And so the guys were super anal about
the weight that they carry to me.
Yeah. So like they would, you know how
the backpack, a backpack has, you know,
a strap that you pull,
you pulled a tightknit,
they'd get it to the port
where it was supposed to be,
give it a little bit second and cut
director, cut the rest off. And so it's,
they don't want to carry that
little extra four inches of nylon,
not going to do it.
They had every piece of gear that
they had would be like that. Yeah.
Dope to warriors at team to truth.
Here's an interesting thing
in passing through water,
the horses must never be allowed to drink.
Okay.
A man who holds to water, his horse will
stop a whole army. When this happens,
the officers should hasten to the spot
and instead of fruitless reprimands and
ill timed mercy, they should
instantly chastise the offender.
Okay.
Nothing is of such importance for
the preservation of the cavalry.
Okay.
Otherwise, the affection the
men they have for their horses,
we'll have them halting little or much,
and then it is impossible for them
to recover their ranks without gallon
discipline.
People get that little affection
further for not just, you know,
I wasn't thinking horses here.
I was thinking about like being on
a long patrol or in the workplace.
You want your team to
go and every time you,
you grant that little bit of mercy.
Right?
Am I saying be merciless straight?
Same driver? No, but when you do it,
you start develop that trend and now it
throws other things off and sometimes
you just gotta be, Hey, no, be
quiet and execute. Yeah, got to go.
Got It.
Go
in time of peace. And in winter
quarters, in time of war,
their horses should be kept in conditioned
by violent exercise or runs at least
three times a week.
I like this idea of violent exercise.
I'm going to start doing violent
exercising. Yeah, that's good.
Like violent.
Exercising the same.
Severe usage is also proper for the
heavy cavalry charge at those times.
It is in the field.
It is only in the field,
but they must be managed carefully to
keep them in flesh and the squadrons
complete and strong,
and this is interesting,
the best chance of teaching them to
stand fire is when the infantry is
practicing.
They should advance on the fire and walk
and be kept calm.
Accosting accustoming them
to go closer and closer.
They should never be beaten
but stroked and encouraged,
encouraged in the space of a month.
They will be so accustomed to it that
they will even put their nose on the
muzzle of the muskets without any fright
or surprise. Then they are all right.
Nevertheless,
they should not be allowed to approach
to close for once they get burned,
you will not be able to
bring them near again.
This ordeal must be reserved for
the day of battle. That was good.
That to me reminded me of what Jordan
Peterson was talking about Ed way or the
warrior kid. How you slowly inoculate
people. You don't throw him into the F,
you don't bring them right
up to the firing line and
start shooting the guns and
let them get freaked out horribly.
You bring them a little distance.
He let them listen from afar and then
bring a little bit closer and then next
thing you know they're good to go.
They're standing in the line.
What do you call that? What did Jordan
Peterson call that? Exposure? Yeah,
gradual exposure.
Therapy exposures.
Graduated exposure therapy.
Something. It's something, yeah,
it was something like that until it
cover,
move a little bit of that.
I am convinced every unit that is not
supported is a defeated organization.
Infantry should always be supported by
cavalry and cavalry by infantry covered
move work together. Support.
Here's a little note back to the book.
The general or commander in chief of
an army should have a standard to be
carried ahead of him
as a mark of his rank,
so he's talking about flags.
This is, this also has a purpose.
Anyone searching for him will
know instantly where to find him,
especially in battle and the troops
seeing the standard will know that the
general is observing them.
So one thing we did and they do
in the military as they, you,
when you're giving your brief on
how the mission is going to go,
you brief location of
leadership, there's a, Oh guys,
we're going to take down
these eight buildings. I'll
be here in this building, uh,
on the top floor. Boom. So if you
need me know where to come find me,
something happens. Hey, where's
this platoon leader going to be yet?
Once we get our targets here,
I'm going to come over here.
I missed out on the backside with
a breach took place if you need me,
that's where I'll be.
So everyone got it.
So you know where everyone is and is he
talking about like having a a standard
that's like a, like a symbol. It's
a flag. Yeah, the actual flag.
An actual flag he's wearing.
Matt wouldn't really know we didn't
do that because isn't there like
a thing? Yes. That's saying like, Hey,
you don't want it. Like, what was it?
I want to say saving private Ryan. He's
like, don't salute. Yeah, year, whatever.
Cause I don't want the enemy to see where.
Yup. Yeah. You definitely don't want
to mark your position when
these guys are general.
And as a matter of fact, and I'm trying
to think of what book we recently did,
where he was talking about like,
yeah, if you're seeing running around,
if you're a radio man or you're seen
running around giving direction,
you're going to get shot. Yeah. Yeah.
The officer that was, he was Vietnam,
I think it was a, I think it was
the battle I drank. But yeah,
they're talking about that. Oh yeah. It
definitely was a battle of wide drank.
It was, cause when they were
leaving they said like within,
within minutes the leaders had been
killed in a radio man had been killed.
The ones that were still
with their elements. So yeah,
that's not something you want to do.
But what we would do is brief where we
are going to be so that everyone on the
team knew based on a terrain
feature. Yeah. You know, hey,
here's this. Here's this building, or
here's this knoll of this mountain,
or here's this intersection's road.
That's where I'll be. That's where I'm,
that's what I'm planning to be. So now
people know where you are. It makes sense.
I mean he had an additional thing
there when when he said, um, so that,
you know, the general
watching kind of thing. Yeah.
I guess that wouldn't really apply to
your situation. No, it wouldn't apply.
Although like in the military when the
general is visiting and as a two star
general, they've raised a two
star flag. Everyone knows it so,
okay. So I guess, yeah, you're right.
So it will be real circumstantial
like during the war combat situation.
Gotcha.
Now he talks about the companies
and again he calls them centuries,
which is basically a company sized
element of around a hundred guys.
And he's saying that they should have
their own little symbols as well and their
own standards back to the book.
If the standards are distinguished
by their different colors,
the actions of every
century will be conspicuous.
This will create the greatest emulation
because both officers and soldiers will
know that they are seen
and that their countenance,
conduct and behavior are not
ignored by the rest of the army.
The men as well as the officers will
tell of it in the field and in garrison
there exploits will be constant.
The constant subject of conversation.
I thought that was kind of a
cool idea. You know, if you're,
if you're flying the flag then people
are watching you and so you better act.
You'd better come correct or represents.
Yeah.
You better represent actually I
like come crack does come correct.
Back to the book after the
Organization of military troops,
military discipline is the first
matter that presents itself.
It is the soul of armies
that is such a nice ring to it
is the soul of the as well,
but I suppose we'll talk about that later.
Back to the book.
If it is not established with wisdom and
maintained with unshakable resolution,
you'll have no soldiers regiments and
armies will be only contemptible armed
mobs more dangerous to their
own country than the enemy.
It is a false idea that discipline,
subordination and slavish obedience,
debase courage.
It has always been noted that it is
with those armies in which the severest
discipline is enforced,
that the greatest deeds are performed.
Many generals believe that they have done
everything as soon as they have issued
orders and that they are and they order
a great deal because they find many
abuses.
So he's saying they're like when a general
feels like he's talking about a bad
general,
what a general feels like.
They've done everything as soon as
they've given their order and since that's
what they do,
they give all kinds of orders or ordered
you to do this and I'm already to do
that. I'm going to order you use
something else. Here's what he says.
This is a false principle
proceeding in this fashion.
They will never reestablished discipline
in an army in which it has been lost or
weekend.
Few orders are best,
but they should be followed up with care.
Negligence should be punished without
partiality and without distinction of rank
or birth.
Otherwise you will make yourself hated.
One can be exact and just and beloved
at the same time as feared severity must
be accompanied with kindness.
But this should not have the
appearance of pretense but of goodness.
And this is just a little note,
I thought everyone should know
whippings need not be severe.
The more moderate they are,
the more quickly we'll abuses be remedied.
Since all the world will
join in ending them.
So even when you're whipping your people,
you know,
be a little bit more judicious.
We have, uh, this is, this
is good too. We have a,
a pernicious custom in France
have always punishing with death.
I'll soldier caught
pillaging is hung the result.
Now what do you think the result of
that would be? That he's going to say,
I'm quizzing you. What's your
guess if you, if you, um,
are pillaging called pillaging, you're
going to get home. What do you think the,
what do you think that happens because of
that happens to who? What do you think?
Why should we not hang
people for pillaging?
Do you think there's a lot of pillage and
going on? If you get caught pillaging,
they hang you or your fellow soldiers. Do
you think they pillage? I say, no. Okay,
you're wrong.
The result is that no one arrests him
because they do not want to cause the
death of a poor devil who is only trying
to live if instead we were only turned
him over to the guard to
be putting chains, contend
to bread and water for one,
two or three months or put to work in,
in at any of the labors that
always have to be done in any army,
and then they were sent to his regiment
before a battle or when the general
wished everyone would agree with this
punishment and the officers of the patrols
would arrest them by the hundreds.
Soon there will be no pillaging because
everyone would join in putting it under
control. So it makes sense. That
is the reason I asked you that,
which I don't normally do is because I
thought the same thing. I was like, well,
what's, where's he going with
this? Oh yeah. It's obvious.
Why don't you think about it?
You're not going to report one of your
guys for stealing something if the
punishment was death. Right.
You know what that is?
That's like that's like small picture
versus big picture. Small picture.
The small picture is like yeah cause
cause you just look at it as yourself,
right? You get your bubble in your head.
You're like I wouldn't pillage if it,
if it, if it was death, I wouldn't pillage
and that's how you're looking at it.
But no big picture is like hey apply
that to everyone applied to the whole
community. Exactly right. If
you tell him this guy pillaging,
you just sentenced him to death.
If you tell on him,
maybe you turn them in and whatever.
That's what you did. Good point. And it's,
I just remembered somebody pointed out
to me, you remember rifleman Harrison.
It starts off when my rifle and Harris
has to execute a guy and I said,
I said on the podcast,
Hey,
this guy's getting executed basically
for desertion and being drunk.
What I didn't realize is if somebody sent
me an email or a social media message,
they said,
hey,
the reason that guy was getting executed
was because he had taken the money for
like 16 enlistments and kept disappearing.
So when you do get a signing
bonus, hey, here's here's,
it was probably nothing but you know,
here's,
here's 10 quid or pound
sterling or whatever,
here's 10 pounds sterling, oh
you're joining the army, cool,
here's 10 and then you take that money,
go get drunk and get crazy and then you
do it again and then you do it again in
a different area because
they have no internet.
They have no way of knowing that this
is the guy when they finally catch him,
he's getting sentenced to death.
Now do I think as you get sentenced
to death either for that? Not really,
but he was doing something more severe
than what I had mentioned on the podcast.
So I just wanted to, while I'm thinking
about that, set the record straight,
but the, the main point here for me,
it's the secondary effects, right?
You think you're going to have? The
primary effect is, Oh, if we do this,
no one's going to, if we're going to
kill you, if you get caught pillaging,
no one's gonna, no one's
gonna pillage anymore. No,
actually no one's gonna report it anymore
cause your punishment is too strong.
This is also how, this is also how
and why. When people think that,
oh, if someone's in the military, the
soldiers just do what they're told wrong.
The soldiers actually there,
there's secondary effects. Oh,
you're going to kill the guys. No,
we're not going to report it then. Yeah,
so there's,
there are secondary effects.
Even though they'd been
ordered to do that,
and they're soldiers and they have
disciplined, they've been training,
he's bragging about discipline
all the time. Guess what?
They don't Paul that order
because the order sucks.
That's what we got to remember.
Not just about the military,
but about business too.
You give people dumb orders or you give
people things that don't make sense,
they're not really going to execute
it the way you'd want them to,
and I'll tell you something else.
You don't want them to execute that way.
Cause if they got hundreds of people
pillaging and you now end up murdering
hundreds of own your own people,
you're affecting your own army,
you're going to get deserters
were working in army like that.
It's the same thing with a business.
You start laying out severe punishment,
punishment that doesn't make sense,
isn't reciprocal to the crime that
was committed. I mean you pillage.
Think about what pillaging is. I
took some bread from the store. Cool.
We're going to shoot you the head. Dang.
The punishment did not fit the crime.
Yeah, in that case. All right.
[inaudible] he's talking
about where to build,
where to build tactical
positions and he says,
and this is just the same thing
you said earlier about people,
but he's talking about
basically talking about terrain.
Now nature is infinitely stronger than
the works of man. Why not profit from it?
Meaning use a river,
use a hill,
use use terrain to build
your defensive positions.
Don't just use a shovel.
Same thing that he talked about
earlier with with human beings.
Now another piece,
many persons believe that is advantageous
to take the field early and this is
coming right back. Sun Tzu art
of war, be there first. Yeah,
Saks maybe doesn't agree with that
a little bit. Here they are. Right.
What does the question of seizing
an important post? Otherwise,
it seems to me that there is no need to
hastened and that one should remain in
winter quarters longer than usual.
So he goes on to talk.
Winter quarters means you're, you're
gonna go out in the field. Well,
we're gonna go out in the field
now and we're going to be cold,
wet and miserable for the next three days
while we wait for the enemy to show up.
And now they show up fresh. Who's
going to do better in the battle? Yeah.
So just to think about,
I used to say the,
the military used to say all the time, you
know, you've got to be forward leaning.
You ever heard that
expression? [inaudible] yeah.
Got To be forward leaning.
And I would say,
let's not be so forward leaning that were
in the leaning rest of leaning rest is
the pushup position. Which they would
leave you in for a long periods of time.
A lot of different training situations.
So sometimes you get so proactive
gets so leaning forward,
a forward leaning that you're in
leaning rest and you're wasting energy.
Just trying to be all prepared.
Like you'd see some guys warm up. You do
such a good warm up that you're tired.
Yeah.
You went so far forward leaning in the
leaning rest and then the other thing is
to not warm up at all. Now you're not
ready, so you've got to find what you got.
That's the dichotomy of leadership. You
got to find a balance between those two.
Yeah.
Another good point here.
Back to the book,
it is absolutely necessary to
accustom soldiers to labor.
If we examine Roman history,
we find we shall find that republic
looked on ease and indolence as the most
formidable enemies.
Yeah.
The console's prepared their legions for
battle by rendering them indefatigable
rather than have them idle,
they employed them on unnecessary works.
Continual exercise makes good soldiers
because it qualifies them for military
duties.
By being habituated to pain,
they insensibly learn to despise danger.
The transition from fatigue to rest.
Enervates them meaning weakens them.
They compare one state
with another and idleness.
That predominant passion of
mankind gains ascendancy over them.
They then murmur at every trifling
inconvenience and their souls soften and
they're emasculated bodies.
Yeah.
So what he's saying is people get used
to the soft ways people get used to the
easy life. And if you let them
get used to it like you, you,
when you want to do something hard,
when it's time to do something hard,
you're not ready for it.
Yeah.
Every minute that Charlie's out in
the bush getting stronger, every time,
almost every day at night I'm spending
in this hotel, it's apocalypse now.
Every night I'm sitting in
this hotel getting softer.
Every night Charlie's out in
the bush getting stronger.
That's what he's talking about here.
That's what he's talking about.
But now do I agree with having
people do unnecessary works? No,
I don't. Because people see
right through that and it just,
you're just being stupid and taking are
going to see that. They're gonna say,
why are we doing this? Dig
The hole, Phillip. Back up,
dig the hole, fill it back up.
No, don't do that. But you know,
we're going to a training exercise.
When you're training exercise, we're
going to get stronger. We're going to get,
we're going to dig a hole, we're going to
put, you know, set it up for a perimeter.
Then we're going to move to another
situation is if we have to back away or,
or collapse our perimeter.
Cause when you collapse a perimeter,
you've got to fill that whole back end.
Otherwise when the enemy comes
to attack you, they use it.
So you got to fill that whole back end.
So let's run a real drill. And by the way,
let's make it into a little contest
and see how fast we can dig in.
And then once we get it dug in,
we're going to set up when see how fast
we can collapse and get it filled back
in.
We're doing it at the end of it,
we're going to give out some
prizes and have a beer. Right?
That's a good tactic by the way. I like
to make a, um, whether it be a game or,
yeah,
you told her is Charles gamified Chelsea
us the game of hockey game of vacation.
Like if you're moving,
you know,
you don't when you're moving your house
or whatever and how fast can I get this
stuff packed up or let me use it
as a little workout, little metcon.
We got to move all of these boxes
upstairs, two floors, whatever.
Let me use it as a workout. It kind
of makes it more enjoyable as well.
But at the same time you get the results
of a, of a little workout right there.
Here, let me ask you this about that.
When you said you didn't agree with the,
the unnecessary, unnecessary
works, this is, what about um,
like pushups as punishment for example,
or a Kettler exercise? An interesting one.
Cause, cause I think,
I think like with kids,
if you make burpees a punishment, they
don't like it. Or if you make it a reward,
they liked them, then you're
better off clear it. Yeah, I agree.
I do that by the way. Yeah, that's
good. You make it a reward. Yeah,
like a we'll need the cool people
do burpees. That's what it is.
They see dead doing burpees,
Dead Dune,
the end of these whatever exercises
or whatever. Only cool people do it.
I kind of pushed hard on that
too, but it's unfair. But
no. The question is though,
in the military, in
the military, not kids,
no calisthenics or definitely punishment
in the military. Yeah, straight up.
It's not until you transitioned out of
the boot camps that you get away from
that now in the seal teams,
like they don't,
you don't do calisthenics as punishment.
I will say that if you mess up,
like for instance when
I was running training,
if the guys performed poorly,
they were going to have more down
men getting, this is a training,
I'm talking about fake down men,
but they're going to have
more men that couldn't walk.
That's more men that have to be carried.
That's punishment in its own right.
That's a punishment.
If you,
when I was running communications course
when I was a younger enlisted seal,
if you missed a communications window,
you had to walk a longer distance.
If you missed multiple, you're going
to have to walk tragic distances. Now.
It wasn't just a natural
result of you missing missing.
Did you impose that? Fine.
Just imposed yesterday was
imposed and they knew it was
imposed. Okay. And and so,
yeah, you, if you miss in the seal teams,
if you miss the extraction point with
a boat's coming to pick you up after a
dive, well now you got to swim to the new
exotic, new, the pickup point. Guess what?
The new pickup point isn't close
because you've compromised.
Now you're above the surface.
Do you need to get away?
And so that means you got
to swim an extra, you know,
maybe it's an extra hour of
surface swimming with a rig
on it, which is not fun.
But it doesn't sound fun cause you
can't, you're, you're not just,
you're not just having fun.
Right. It's called turtle back.
You're laying on your back cause
it's really awkward. It's, it's,
it's comfortable to
dive with our dive rig.
We have a dive rig that's,
it's called a rebreather and it goes
on your chest and it's small. It's not,
it's not tiny. Closed circuit.
It's closed circuit. Yeah,
look at you look at you big time.
So it's a closed circuit dive rig,
but when it runs out you can't,
it doesn't work anymore so you have to
swim and we do something called turtle
back generally,
which is basically you're laying on
your back and you're just fending and it
takes a long time to move very
far and it's not comfortable.
So the punishment is in training. If you
miss your extraction point, that's fine.
You just got to swim to the
alternate extraction point.
The alternate extraction point is not
going to be close by because you screwed
up.
Same thing with if you miss
your helicopter extraction
because you took too long
on target and then you got bogged down
and it took you a long time to move all
these down people. That's, I
mean it happens. Understand that,
but now you have to walk to
the secondary extraction point,
which happens to be six kilometers
up a hill. Yeah, see, but that's,
to me, and this is me pinking
whatever, 10 seconds about it.
That seems like that makes perfect sense.
In fact,
that seems like a cool little strategy
because in real life that's how it works.
You use the bus, you ride the
bus to school, you miss the bus,
you're walking to school or
riding your bike, whatever.
It's kind of that thing that's,
that's how life deals it to you a lot
of the time. Like these types of things,
what you're saying. But
let's say, hey you, you know,
your shoes aren't shined or
whatever. I Dunno, aren't shying,
give me 50 push ups or they
don't do it in the seal teams.
They definitely do it in the army.
They definitely do it in the Rangers
Rangers that they're dropping down all the
time and, but no, we don't do that. And
so that's the question though. Do you,
do you agree with that or do you
even think about that kind of stuff?
I don't think about that kind of stuff.
Yeah. I think being, I would say that I,
that I would not do it when I was in a
military leadership position just because
I would rather, I dunno. Yeah, it's weird.
It feels like it just makes sense when
I know that the army runs it that way.
It makes sense. And by the way,
when the army does it, and I,
I shouldn't even say anything else about
the way the army does it cause I'm not,
I don't know exactly how
they implement that strategy.
So next time we have Tim Kennedy on,
we'll get them to give us a full debrief
on that and we'll get another, another,
a range around here to give us a full
debrief on that. Here's something,
so I was watching the show,
ran this random show me my
wife before we were married,
when we were just dating whatever.
We'd watch these random shows and it
was a kind of like a reality show,
kind of like a competition show. But
it was, I think army, like you know,
you grab regular people,
put them in army scenario,
you give them like missions and it's like,
cause they have a ranger,
they have a best ranger every year.
They have a best ranger competition,
which are really hardcore competition.
Well, it was, it was, you know,
it's a lot like the FTX a lot like
that, but it's a whole like, you know,
you're there for like a month or whatever
and same but a lot of drill sergeant
type situations dropping,
give me 2050 whatever. Right.
So it was towards the end of the season
or whatever and this girl was like,
she was like, Dang, look how strong
and like muscular my arms are now.
This is just from all the push ups
we had to do and stuff like that.
Just by happenstance. Sure.
She was getting punished. Sure.
She was learning to you follow directions
more meticulously and all this stuff
that you learned from, you
know, the whole, you know,
orders versus punishment situation,
but as kind of a byproduct if you will,
she has some physical strength. No. You
know, wonder if that has something to do.
Maybe you're definitely,
you're definitely making people stronger.
There's no doubt about it. Yeah. So
that's all positive for sure. Yeah.
There's no doubt the
great bright biproduct of,
of calisthenics as punishment
is you get stronger.
But like
in the, in the seals it's weird. It's
weird. It's not a thing. It's not a thing.
Okay, you're going to drop down and
give me 50 like that deliberately.
I never saw that happen.
A single,
it might've happened with new
guys sometimes like occasion,
like a new guy that you're not getting
through to him. Okay. Guess what?
But even with new guys, if you really
want to get through to who got what,
you want them to be good at his tactics,
not push up to people in teams.
You're supposed to do pushups on your own.
Man was like,
we're not in here to teach you how
to do pushups. Like you need to,
you need to be in shape.
But we want to make better things to
do what I was going to say. But here,
but at the same time you can't help
but wonder. Maybe that's just like,
that's a certain way of looking at
it, which is good. Seems obvious.
Seems effective to me. But what if
there's something like that, you know,
like something from back in the day,
some old school fundamental principle
that that's kind of why you do it.
That's super innovative.
Maybe that's why in the teams they don't
do it because they want you to be self
disciplined. Not like
specific, yeah. Not, not self.
Not disciplined by the group but in post.
But yeah,
you don't want to impose discipline
interest so well regardless,
I think that you should train hard because
you don't want to have your soul gets
softened inside of your
emasculated Bhakti.
That just sounds like something,
I don't want to be a part of that,
so I'll keep training
back to the book.
There is more skill in one might think.
Then my then one might think and
making poor dispositions intentionally,
but one must be able to change
them into good ones in an instant.
So he's talking about how you set yourself
up in a bad position only to let the
enemy try and maneuver on that.
Put your waiting for me when
you're ready and do something.
You change your position and do something
good like in Jujitsu when you're
getting let someone set up a triangle,
but you're just trying to pass
their guard. Gotcha. Yeah.
Nothing is more
disconcerting to the enemy.
He has counted on a certain thing,
has disposed himself accordingly and at
the instant of attacking it has changed.
So, so this is, this
is pretty cool, right?
This is a good thing to remember.
I like when you talk about
us is psychological effect
that it has on the enemy.
So the enemy sees something,
they expect something,
they want something to go a certain way.
So they arrange themselves for it.
And then right when they're
getting ready to execute it,
they realize it wasn't what they thought.
And he says,
there's nothing more disconcerting.
And I'd say that's true with a person to
the unexpected is what disturbs people.
Especially you see this all the time
in MMA where a guy gets close to a
submission and then he'd get, the other
guy gets out and he expanded on gender,
genders. You can see the,
you can see the, the,
the moral draining from
their face when it present.
It's bad sometimes. Dude, sometimes
he go, he goes on, I repeat.
Nothing confuses him so greatly and
leads him into more serious faults.
If he does not change his disposition,
he will be defeated.
And if he changes them in the presence
of the enemy, he will still be defeated.
Human Spirit cannot meet it.
I'm trying to think of how that affects
someone's psych. Oh yeah. It affects,
it definitely affects you psychologically.
Like you throw the,
you think it would get this person,
that triangle,
you put it on there and
then all of a sudden, boom.
You realize it's not just
that you missed the triangle,
it's so you realize that you got played
and that doesn't feel good and that
can definitely hurt your morale. Yeah.
Big Time.
That's a little different than just
missing the move when you realize you got
set up actually,
that it messes up your whole
game. So, okay, so you wrote
with stilts, right? Yeah.
Okay. So that's, that's a, I don't
want to say that's his whole game,
but that's his game right there.
So like if you go, you know,
side control or mount or whatever, he has
dangerous, we wants to there one. Yes,
exactly right.
So it's like,
and every once in a while you get
rolling with them like kind of hard.
It'll seem like he's
trying to defend them out,
but he's really letting you think that
you got the mountain right. You know,
cause even if you're like,
if is letting you mount,
you know they're letting you mouth and
if they're going to spring some sort of a
trap, it's going to be more obvious
if they're letting you do it.
But you get them where he kind of lets
you do it to the point where you don't
realize he's, yeah, you just got,
and then from there after a while
he keeps doing stuff like that too.
You're like,
Bro,
I don't even really want to do anything
to him because he's just going to send
me, this is just a bunch of traps right
now. So it messes up your whole game.
You can't do anything on
your own accord though.
It's not like he's preventing
you from doing anything.
It's like you're preventing
yourself now that's a,
that's a situation he has to deal with.
But actually actually I figured it out.
I figured out,
I didn't figure it out.
I figured out a method to deal with
just that whole scenario with him,
by the way. And he even asked me
afterwards, so I was like, oh, let's,
I was going hard. And I was, you know
how you get real like weary like okay,
I know he's gonna send me. So it was
real uneventful role. So I was like, Hey,
let's go roll again.
And then I just loosened up and basically
allowed him to spring whatever trap he
wants, I need. Danny did all
this stuff and he was like, Hey,
you were rolling a lot lighter
in that time. I was like, no bro,
I'm just trying to,
I'm trying to turn on the lights to
all your traps that you sit, you know?
So it's Kinda like that thing just
comes with like the type of training.
Like you can't regard the
training as a competition. Yeah.
You got to go in and be like, you are
not learning anything. Yeah. But man,
you know, in a war battle or in a
competition scenario, it's like,
I'm trying to think if I ever got played
like that on the battlefield. You know,
sometimes we'd hit a target
and it was real obvious that,
you know,
we had,
I wouldn't say set up,
but like there's no one there.
Like clearly the information that we
got was wrong and you'd be kind of like
Dang, you know, be like man that
that wasn't good. And it really,
on a real rudimentary level it,
that's what an IED is. You know,
it's like they want to make it
look like a trashcan or a regular,
there's something you have to address
or something like that. You know, some,
a place where you have to go anyway,
the road, I don't know what a,
on a real simple level,
that's kind of what that is.
So now you're like shooting all,
we've got to be weary of everyday things,
normal protocol. We've got to be
weary of that. That's a, that's a,
that's a digger on the psychology
for sure. Back to the book.
I do not care for either one.
Oh sorry.
It's his lines and entrenchment.
So he's talking about lines and
entrenchments meaning defensive positions.
I do not care for either the
one or the other of these works.
When I hear talk of lines,
I always think I am hearing
of talk of the walls of China.
The good ones are those that nature has
made and the good entrenchments are good
dispositions and brave soldiers.
Again,
just capitalizing on nature and saying
that brave soldiers are more important
than your position.
Man always fears the consequences
of danger more than danger itself.
Totally true.
When,
and I'll tell you what's equally or
you could throw in there as the w the
anticipation of danger is probably
the worst thing. You know,
I see this,
I see a lot of kids on the wrestling mat
right now cause it's wrestling season
and you can see kids get nervous
before they get on the map,
but then once to get them the math
during the game and now you're,
now you're doing your job. But the
anticipation of what could happen. Yeah.
Drives people crazy. When
is that like, you know,
cause you gotta you felt that before
bringing it back to the day when we were
competing. Yeah. That
like Jujitsu tournament.
Civil war especially back actually your,
one of your last competition was
my first competition or way? Yeah.
Where was that in la? It's called like
the Pan Am's of submission grappling.
It wasn't the Pan Am's Pan Ams.
It was like I think like submission
grappling and it was, no, how did I do?
Uh, I dunno. I Dunno. I remember,
remember I remember seeing all the
pictures cause one of the, it's funny,
one of the like tournament,
it was a tournament. Yeah.
So I remember Alicia photos.
Remember that Anna who ran it?
Who ran the tournament?
I have no idea.
I didn't even know there was tournaments
and I saw one hour or brand at the time
was like, yeah, the term. I was like, oh
we can have tournament. I was like boom.
So I just jumped on it real quick.
What was the iconic photo?
I say it's iconic because it's a kind
of a much strong word, a very strong,
it's not a clinic at all actually,
but it's okay. I'm so, I'm, we,
I have this guy,
his name is Jim.
You'll probably know Jim. He, uh,
I have him in a,
it's not an American,
it's a straight arm lock and
I wound up tapping him out.
And Alicia photos though.
That was the photographer at the time.
The main one really good picture of it.
It was such a good picture.
It was in the front of her
website. The picture. Right.
That's why I call it iconic photo
full on this.
Everyone knows that photo.
Everyone,
they probably do if they're
competing back in the day,
if they know Lisa Phillips Anyway, um,
the full on like novice division. Right.
I was like, I had been trying for
two months, twice a week, by the way,
for two months. Boom. Enough.
I'm still just dominating
out there right now.
I actually lost, I lost my
first match. Took third.
Nonetheless, it doesn't matter.
Um, so I know that you did it because
when I was looking through the pictures,
it was you compete,
I think you were competing against like,
so could you or somebody I think,
but I remember [inaudible] yeah,
well it was maybe, I don't know,
some other black guy, but I don't
know. I remember it was you,
cause I remember like you,
I'll have to check that out and
then the last to explore that.
But what was the point that, oh
yeah, waiting for the match is like,
that's the nerve wracking part.
Like growling,
even when you step on the match and
you see the guy in front of you getting
right by, that's not nerve racking at
all. That's like everyday you see that
iconic picture of Sarge is a pretty
iconic, and he, it was going against
one of the Gracies kids.
So it was Henner or I think it was
Hallock was at Holland and he's,
but he's double like him.
You know what I'm talking,
sergeants got like the
sadness double heck,
which sergeant has a savage is
another thing. When I see these,
by the way, talking about
Brian, sergeant, uh,
one of my buddies who has a Jiu
Jitsu school in Connecticut,
it's called Jujitsu life,
but he is,
he's a good wrestler.
But when I see these kids and he,
he wrestled a Poway high
school, which is, uh,
one of the best wrestling high
schools maybe in the country.
I mean, it's definitely
incredible program. And he
went there and wrestled there.
And I see occasionally I'll see a kid
that's just has sergeants attitude.
And I saw one of this last tournament,
this kid was just all over it and go,
I mean, it looked, it
didn't look fair, right?
I mean he was just murdering this
kid from Poway was getting after.
It was pretty awesome to watch
and you could see just boom, boom,
boom is hitting the devils.
But it reminded me of the
iconic picture of Sarge.
Oh, there's a picture of it. So
yeah, there's a picture of sergeant.
They put him on. They, it was, it was,
it was one of those pictures that was
so good that they put it like on the
covers,
I think.
I don't know if it was that one or
if it happened later in the match.
He was double liking him out of bounds,
like he was into the table.
So you gotta, you gotta Watch
out for sergeant double legs,
they'll put you on your,
I asked quick. Yup.
And he wants to start one.
Hard to submit.
So like you just got taken
down. That's two points, right?
And now what are you going to do?
Because you can't sweep sarge right card.
I mean, of course you
can, but it's hard. Yeah.
You only have a few minutes
and it's hard to submit. Oh,
but you got back to your feet. Cool.
He just got taken out of. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the rub with the real good judo
guys are wrestling guys. That's the rub.
What's the rub? Oh, how do you solve that
problem? Me become a better wrestler,
typically. That's not
it. Yeah, Tyrone Woodley,
Tyrone Woodley fought
Damian my year and Damien.
Damien is an incredible Jujitsu player
and he couldn't get tiring down to the
mat.
And every time he shot I would hit my son.
And because every time,
every time Damian shot,
he would s tire and would just stuff
the shot and I hit my son and go,
that's why you wrestle.
That's where you Russell boy,
because you are going to be
able to take people down.
And then once you get to the ground,
if you have the Jujitsu,
well now you've got problems because
the tire and didn't want to go to the
ground with Damien. No, because that
would have been very problematic for him.
But Tyron Woodley is a wrestler.
Oh you know,
was that you who said that the difference
between someone who can wrestle versus
a restless wasn't mean laser.
And that's why I say
that's not the problem.
That's why I say that's not the solution.
If you have a wrestler,
all of these taking you down and the
solution is to get better or ethylene the
sound solution because you want to get
better at something that this guy is
probably getting better. And
this is just, chances are,
I'm not saying it's an absolute,
but he's probably a getting better,
be already super good at it.
So it's like the solution is that you
say something and he's 12 years ahead of
you. Yeah. He's eight years ahead
of you in a wrestling. Yeah. Yeah.
So that's not the solution. I don't know
what to do. I'm not saying don't wrestle.
Well I think I'll tell you what the s
what I think the solution is off the top
of my head.
You learn enough wrestling and then
you figured out how to incorporate your
Jujitsu into the wrestling. So that,
and I say this all the time and,
and dean will tell you the same thing.
Dean will,
a dean will hesitate to
shoot on me because he knows
there's significant threats
there.
He'll shoot all day on a good wrestler
because he doesn't care what happens.
They're not going to, they're not
going to catch him most likely. I mean,
obviously I did Jujitsu wrestler, it's
can happen, but, and I feel the same way.
I'll shoot, I'll shoot all day on a,
on a good wrestler cause I don't care.
They're not going to catch me anything.
And if they do,
I'll be able to do the proper
defense and escape it. But Dean, no.
Like no, that's a real problem. Same with
Andy. You shoot on Andy, you're, you know,
it's like okay that can be problematic
and not even just pay for it.
You can lose right there. Yeah.
Yeah. Andy and I have been a problem.
Whoever shoots Lou,
whoever shoots loses. Yeah.
Cause we're both have good anti wrestling.
So yeah, that's it. That's the pro.
That's the solution there.
You've got to figure out that the counter,
the Kryptonite to the wrestling, right.
In whatever way. Cause that's not just,
Oh yeah, just do that. That's not how it
is. It, it's, but that's the direction.
That's the solution.
There's problems with that.
Well there's not problems with that.
One of the easiest ways is to be very,
I guess this is a problem,
is to be very non aggressive because if
all you're trying to do is avoid getting
taken down,
you already are,
are a lot harder to take
down than if you're like,
if I go in and start trying
to take down a wrestler,
they're going to put me on my ass because
I'm trying to take them and they know
their counters that much better
than timings that much better.
They hit the switch phone.
I'll also, I'm down, you know,
but if I'm just trying to avoid you,
it's the same thing with somebody that's
a really good striker. If you're just,
if your goal is to,
if you start striking with the
Stryker that's better than you,
you are more likely to get knocked out.
You're more Luton like to get hit because
you're playing there. That's the point.
You're playing their game and you
don't want to play their game.
Now what sucks about that, and it
even happened to Tyron Woodley fight.
It was a boring fight because
it was shots getting stuffed.
Stand up just a little. Some striking
shots, getting stuffed, stand up to play,
striking shots, getting stuff.
That's what the fight was.
It was a very boring fight because his
goal is to not get taken down and he's a
wrestler, so he had the capability
of doing it and that was that.
I'll tell you what it does, what
you do for, for wrestling situation,
one of the simple,
it's not easy at all,
but you find a way to get
to the back from the bottle.
Well, yeah, that's great. Yeah. You
find a way to submit mum, submit them.
That's great to get to the,
because depend told me them to their band,
get on their back.
So for sure on their back he was,
he told me this when he was going
to fight Chael Sonnen [inaudible] a
[inaudible] and he was like, he
was like, yeah, it's interesting.
Fighting wrestlers or whatever.
It's like they can provide like that.
I'm totally paraphrasing.
They can provide these really hard
situations for you in Jujitsu for many
reasons of super hard and hard people
to fight. But if you can figure it out,
you got to figure out ways where
wrestling provides weaknesses in an in,
in a Jujitsu scenario. Yeah. And then
if you watch the match, sure enough,
like he was [inaudible] was really
good at stuffing stuff in stuffing,
stuffing and then you could see golf.
I was like just slowly and then he got
to the guts of the bat and I used to
coach Dean with the same idea of do
you know if he was going against a good
wrestler? I'd say use your Jujitsu if
he's going against, get good Jujitsu guy,
guide,
say use your wrestling.
Dean would have a tendency because of his
personality to want to go against them
in their strength.
So he tried out wrestle wrestlers.
He tried out Jujitsu attributes,
you guys? He would, he would,
that's his natural tendency would be to
go at people's strengths and I'd have to
like say no,
do Jujitsu against this guy and then
he'd do it and get what he needed to get.
All right back to the book.
When one is obliged to
defend entrenchments,
one should post all the
battalions directly behind
the parapet because if once
the enemy sets foot upon that,
those in the rear we'll think of
nothing but to save themselves.
This is because of the consternation
in men when something happens that they
have not expected.
Again,
conservation is shock,
so he's again emphasizing the fact that
when people aren't expecting something,
it is a major down her for it's
a major down for Macquarie.
It interrupts what's happening and that's
why you got to think of contingencies.
That's one of the biggest things that,
well,
one of the best things about thinking
about contingencies is just that you're
aware of.
It's going to have that you've thought
about it for half a second big tip that
makes you so much better
off getting caught complete,
getting caught completely off guard.
I mean this happens in Jujitsu.
The thing that you get caught with is the
thing that you didn't see coming. Yeah,
that's,
that's the thing that catches you.
The thing that surprises you and you're
like, how'd that happen? It surprise you.
That's what you get caught with.
Even like in your house?
Like that's the one I think of a lot
where you know when you're in your house
and, and if you think of like what
if there's someone in here? Oh yeah,
right now you're not even necessarily
of how scary that would be necessarily,
but it's like, okay, what
if there's someone in here,
at least I'm ready for the fact
that someone's in here, my daughter,
my eight year old daughter
will try and scare me. Yeah.
And she'll hide somewhere
and if I don't expect it,
I get started get and then, and
then what I do is I just, you know,
you're talking about punishments?
No. What? I know I punished myself.
So she's shows she scared
me twice last year.
Like that actually made
me a little bit startled.
She tried to 98 times 96
of them were ineffective,
but I'll tell you what,
I, I punished myself
burpee school and then,
but I really enjoy scaring people.
It's sure a lot.
I don't know why.
I find it very entertaining
and funny and satisfying.
So I do, when I scare
people, like makes them cry.
Have you scare him? Do you do the like
the loud noise one or do you think, yeah.
You know, cause a lot of times the loud
noise isn't the scary thing. Right.
And sometimes the scratching
at the window is a lot. Yeah.
Sometimes you think you're home alone,
you think your dad's calling and then all
of a sudden there's like scratching at
the window and then there's a noise of
the door opening and you start calling
out for your dad but he doesn't answer.
And then there's more scratching at the
window and then all of a sudden there's
someone with a mask on the coating.
You can do that.
That's a violation. You can't do that
with. But I do do that. Yeah. Yeah.
So anyways,
that's that. Back to the book, he said,
well let me catch us up to where we,
we're talking about the shock that
happens when people don't expect something
back to the book.
This is a general rule in war and
decides all battles and all actions.
It comes from the human heart and he's
what induced me to compose this work.
I do not believe that anyone
yet has attempted to find their,
find their the reasons for the
poor success of armies. Thus,
when you have stationed your
troops behind a pair of put,
they hope by their fire to prevent the
enemy from passing the ditch and mounting
it. If this happens in spite of the fire
and they give themselves up for lost,
lose their heads and fly, it would
be much better to post a single rank.
There aren't pikes whose business will
be to push these st went back as fast as
they attempt to mount,
and certainly they will execute this
duty because it is what they expect and
what they prepared for.
If with this,
you post infantry formed according
to my method into centuries,
at a distance of 30 paces
from the entrenchment,
these troops will see that they are placed
there to charge the enemy as fast as
he enters and attempts to form.
They will not be astonished to see the
enemy enter because they expect it and
we'll charge vigorously.
Instead,
if instead they had been placed on
the parapet, they would have fled.
That is how a trifle changes everything
in war and how human weaknesses cannot
be managed except by allowing for them.
That's,
that's heavy right there.
Human weaknesses cannot be managed.
You have to allow for them.
Think about that, that, you know, you
have to do that all time as a leader,
you have to,
well you have to try and do it as a
leader because if you don't try and manage
these weaknesses, you, you,
you don't allow for them,
then they're going to, they're going
to jam you up as you would say.
So you've got somebody with
a big ego, you, you to put,
you gotta put them in a situation where
that ego's gonna flourish and not be
offended. And, and when
it does get offended,
you got to allow for that and
how you're going to adapt to it.
It's like expecting perfection, you know?
You know, like if you expect perfection,
yeah, well you're going to be let
down a bunch. This is what I'm saying.
So if you allow for imperfection is going
to, you can, you can just manage better.
So there's two major points,
you know, number one,
if you set people up so
that what they expect,
what they expect to happen happens,
they're going to have a better chance
of achieving what it is you want them to
achieve.
Because if these guys are in the parapet
and all of a sudden they get run upon
and they're surprised by it and their
mission was defend the pair of pit,
well now they're, they're getting
overrun. Whereas if you say no,
once they pair up, it gets
taken, you attack. Now they're,
they know the parapets going,
it's not going to be surprised them they
expected to happen and then when they,
they get the opportunity, they're going
to get in there and get after it. But man,
allowing the,
the manage managing human weakness,
Oh, you only way you can do
this by allowing for it. At
least some measure of it.
Yeah. Good. Good lesson learned.
That's something you can think about as
you lead people. You can think about,
hey man, this is a little weakness
here and if I don't allow for that,
I don't give that some room
and I count on, you know, uh,
Flynn Flynn from echelon front,
newest member of echelon front,
but he just wrote an article about a guy,
he was stationed on a ship before he got
to the teams and he was saying this guy
had been late for work and,
but he was trying to bring the guy along.
He had a lot of potential,
blah, blah, blah. Anyways,
they go to actually do a, uh,
important training with their weapons
on the ship that they were on.
And the guy missed the ship leaving port
and he says,
you know,
I should have fired the guy
before this and now I'm out here.
I don't have this primary guy and he
let down me and let down the ship and
everything like that. But he didn't
account for human weakness. He, you know,
he fought that he could bring this
guy along, but he just, you know,
it's one of those things if you don't
allow for that human weakness in there,
you might be, you might be getting
left high and dry, which is not good.
That's on the made that thing
on the echelon front webpage,
which is called the platoon hut.
And it was just like writing little,
I guess it could be referred to as a blog.
It's not really a blog or the blog to
me seems a very, you know, just hey,
we're going to write whatever blog.
So this is, this is some little,
I guess you might want to
call them articles. Yeah.
And there's like let like let little
lessons. Yeah, yeah, of course.
Little lessons I, yeah, I liked, I
didn't enjoy platoon hut the whole,
the whole time.
And the reason we call it a platoon
hood is because that's where you'd sit
around and talk shop. I guess we
were talking about other things,
but when you get back from a training op,
because when you're overseas you,
you still have a platoon hub,
but it's not the platoon and I guess it
is the platoon not, but anyways, yeah,
even there. So when you get back from
an operation, you'd come into debrief,
debriefing you,
you get done with the official debrief,
but then you go into the platoon hood,
Hey, you should do this. And so, yeah.
So that's one of those,
he as a young
surface warfare officer in the Navy didn't
allow for the human weakness of this
young sailor and in costume
going back to the book,
the Greeks were very skillful in
the art of war and well disciplined,
but they're large Phalanx was never
able to contend with the small bodies of
Romans dis disposed in this formation.
Now he goes on to,
there's a guy named [inaudible] and he
goes on to quote a huge chunk of text
from police because police
was a Greek historian.
And [inaudible] actually talked about
why the Roman armies could defeat the
failings and pretty interesting.
So here's what he said.
It is easy to demonstrate by many reasons
that while the failings retains its
proper form and full power of action,
no force is able to stand against it
in front or in support of the violent
attack.
So while the Phalanx is in order,
you're not going to be able to defeat it.
So the Phalanx is a military formation
and he talks a little bit about what it's
made up of here.
When the ranks are closed in order to
engage each shoulder as he stands with his
arms, occupies a space of three feet.
The spears in their ancient form,
we're 17 cubits long.
A cubit is about 18 inches,
but for the sake of rendering
them more commodious and actions,
they have since been reduced to 14 of
these four cubits are contained between
the part which the soldier grasps in
his hands and the lower end of the spear
behind which serves as a counterpoint
to the part that is extended before him
and when and the length of this last
part from the body of the soldier.
When the spear is pushed forwards with
both hands against the enemy is in
consequence 10 cubic cubits from.
Hence it follows that when the Phalanx
is closed and it's proper form,
every soldier pressed within the necessary
distance with respect to the man that
has before him and on his side
the spears of the fifth rank,
our extended to the length of two
cubits and those are the second,
third and fourth two is still greater
length beyond the formal strength.
It is manifest manifest then that several
spears differing each other in the
length of two cubits are extended before
every man in the foremost rank and when
it is considered likewise that the
Phalanx is formed by 16 in depth,
it will be easy to conceive what must
be the weight and violence of the entire
body and how great the
force of its attack.
So you got guys 16 people deep,
16 people deep and they've
got these spears and they
adjust the spears depending
on where you are in the ranks.
So the guy that's five ranks back still
has a little bit of his spear sticking
out. And by the way, if one
of those guys goes down,
there's another 14 people
there ready to take his place.
So the Phalanx was locked together.
The shields protecting the person to
your left and it's like a porcupine of
death locked together and obviously the
the Greeks were hardcore warriors and
this is what they use and
they use to crush people.
Would this Phalanx crush them? Spears
and shields, that's all you see
now plebe IOUs talks about what the
Romans did and what their setup was.
Back to the book to each of the
Roman soldiers as he stands in arms,
is a lot of the same space of three feet.
But as every soldier in time of
action is constantly in motion,
being forced to shift this
shield continuously so that
he may cover any part of
his body against which a stroke is aimed
and to vary the position of his sword
so as to either push or
to make a falling stroke.
There must be also a
distance of three feet.
The least that can be allowed for
performing these motions with advantage
between each soldier and the
man that stands next to him,
both on his side and behind him. So the
Romans are in the same similar position,
but they're moving individually inside
these little positions so they're not
working together. They're,
they're more mobile.
It will be easy therefore
to conceive that wall,
the Phalanx retains its proper
position and strengths. No troops,
as I have before observed can, uh,
support the attack of it in front.
So if you're going to get the Phalanx,
you're going to lose if
you're going in front
to what cause then is it described that
the Roman armies are victorious and
those defeated that employed the Phalanx.
So how was it that the Romans
were able to beat the failings?
This is the cause in war.
The Times and places of action
are various and indefinite,
but there is only one time and place one
fixed and determined manner of action
that is suited to the failings.
In the case of a general action.
If an enemy be forced to encounter with
the failings in the very time and place,
which the latter requires,
it is probable in the highest degree
that the failings must obtain victory.
So if you fight the Phalanx where
the Phalanx wants you to fight it,
meaning on a big open area,
you're going to lose.
But if it is possible to avoid an
engagement in such circumstances,
and it is indeed easy to do it,
there is nothing to be dreaded
from this order of battle.
And here's where it gets
to the nitty gritty.
It is well known and acknowledged truth
that the Phalanx requires a ground that
is plain and naked and free from
obstacles of every kind such as trenches,
breaks and browse of hills
or the channels of rivers,
and that any of these are sufficient to
impede it and to dissolve it the unto
dissolve the order in which it was formed.
If the enemy coming down down on it should
lead their army through the country,
plundering the cities in
ravaging the lands of what use,
then we'll be the Phalanx.
So all you have to do is get
them on some rough terrain.
You get them on some rough terrain
and that Phalanx, I mean it's,
it's hard to march already.
We know that,
but now we're marching against weird
terrain and the guy in front of you trips
and falls while heat.
What does he hit?
He hits a rock and how that makes this
guy fall and all of a sudden we got a big
disaster on our hands back to the book.
When the Romans attacked
the failings in the front,
they never employ all their forces so as
to make their line equal to that of the
enemy,
but lead on only a part of their troops
and the rest they keep in reserve.
Now,
whether the troops,
the Phalanx break the line that is
opposed to them or whether they are broken
themselves, the formation peculiar
to the Phalanx is alike dissolved.
So even if they win
that initial onslaught,
even if the Phalanx wins,
that the Phalanx is out of order.
Hmm.
If they pursue the fugitive or if on the
other hand they retreat and our pursued,
in either case they're separated from
the rest of their own body and thus there
is left some space which the reserve of
the Roman army takes care to seize and
then charges the remaining
part of the Phalanx.
But the charge is not made against the
front but in the flank or the rear.
Since it is easy then to
avoid the conditions that
are favorable to the Phalanx
and since those on the contrary
that are disadvantaged,
disadvantageous to it
can never be avoided.
It is certain that this difference alone
must carry with it a decisive wait in
time of action. So let them get a little
bit disrupted once they're disrupted,
flank them.
Hmm.
The troops of the Phalanx lose all their
strength when they engage in separate
companies or man on man.
The Roman order on the contrary has never
attended even on such occasions with
any disadvantage among the Romans.
Every single soldier when he is once
armed and ready for service is a like
fitted and engaged,
fitted to engage in any time or place
on any appearance of the enemy and
preserves the always the same power
and the same capacity in action,
whether in separate
companies or man to man.
So big destructive
element in front of you.
Don't go head on head with it.
We've learned this over and over again.
You might want to distract it.
Sure,
but then you hit him from the flank
and don't face people on their best
category, right? Don't wrestle
against the rest of their,
don't you just threw against the Jujitsu
guy. Don't box against the boxer.
Don't go at them and don't do
it where they want to do it.
That's a real important,
disrupting the Phalanx.
[inaudible].
Now we talks about attacking
entrenchments, which again,
these are defensive positions.
When an entrenchment is to be attacked,
an attempt should be made to extend the
lines as much as possible. Makes Sense,
right?
I just don't want to,
I want to let make the person think that
we're going to tack them on the whole,
the whole line that he's got.
This will make the enemy
fearful everywhere so that
he will not withdraw troops
from any point to reinforce
that what you intend to attack.
Even after he discovers it, this makes
many of his troops. Uselessness was d day,
so what we did on d day,
you know,
they did those massive
deception operations. The Brits,
the Americans have built those fake tanks
and fake planes and put them all there.
They were inflatable. You've
seen that stuff right there.
You seeing that? Oh yeah.
The Americans and the Brits.
When we were trying to to confuse Hitler
about where we were going to attack d
day,
they made these,
we made like fake airplanes and fake
tanks and they put them in different
locations that indicated that we'd
probably be attack in this spot instead of
that spot and it all works and so
he had to defend the whole line.
He actually defended those
areas where they fought.
The attack was coming more than they
defended the area or d day was cool.
Little deception operation.
No.
Okay.
Back to the book. Too much attention
cannot be paid, despise and guides.
They are like eyes and are equally
necessary to a gen general.
He is uh, too much money cannot
be spent to get good ones.
These men should be chosen in the
country where the war is being fought.
They should be intelligent.
Cloning and discreet
spies.
Okay.
The commanding general, I have formed
a picture of a commanding general,
which is not CIM miracle.
I have seen such men.
The first qualities, the first of all
qualities is courage. Without this,
the others are of little value
since they cannot be used.
The second is intelligence,
which must be strong and
fertile in expedience.
The third is health.
He should possess a talent for
sudden and appropriate improvisation.
That's a good,
you don't expect that a talent for sudden
and appropriate improv improvisation.
If I didn't make this clear enough,
he's kind of going through the
characteristics that he believes a good
commanding general should have.
He should be able to penetrate the
minds of other men while remaining
impenetrable himself.
He should be endowed with a capacity of
being prepared for everything with the
activity, with activity,
companied by judgment,
with the skill to make proper decision
on all occasions and with exactness of
discernment,
good lists.
He should have a good disposition,
free from from caprice,
and be a stranger to hatred and caprices
like you're just going to change your
mind all the time.
He should punish without mercy,
especially those core dearest to him,
but never from anger.
Okay.
You remember earlier he was talking
about be kind of chill with it,
with the lashings, but he says
you should punish without mercy,
especially those who are dearest to you.
And I think that goes to what you
were saying about troops. Hey,
you're going to draft people.
You've got to make sure you
draft the rich people too.
And I think you saying you've got to treat
people fairly, right, even when you're,
even when it's in your voice.
Yeah.
He should always be grieved when he is
forced to execute the military rules and
should have the example of moneyless
constantly before his eyes and Manlius
actually actually Manlius he
was like a Roman a hero during,
during the Golic siege and he,
but beyond that,
he was sort of like a,
I want to call my human rights advocate,
but maybe that's too strong of a word.
But anyways,
he ended up getting a crucified,
not crucified, thrown from him,
okay.
From, from a great height
and killed as Zach execution.
But he's sort of seen
as a guy that stood up.
He almost was in like an Alamo scenario,
like in Texas when the, when they,
when they stood and were killed,
he was in one of those situations,
but he wasn't killed during that galaxy.
Jerome. Anyways, back to the book,
Kesha Discard the idea of that is he
who punishes and should persuade himself
and others that he only
administers the military laws
with these qualities,
you'll be loved.
He will be feared and without doubt
obeyed the functions of a general are
infinite. He must know how to subsist
his army. And how to husband it,
how to place it so that it will
not be forced upon to fight,
except when he chooses how to form
his troops in an infinity of different
infinity of different dispositions,
how to profit from that favorable moment
which occurs in all battles and which
decides their success.
All these things are of immense importance
and are as varied as the situations
and dispositions which produced them.
Yeah.
In order to see all these things,
the general should be occupied with
nothing else. The day of the battle,
the inspection of the terrain and the
disposition of his troops should be prompt
like the flight of an eagle.
This done,
his orders should be short
and simple as for instance,
the first line of attack,
the first line will attack and the second
will be in support. Boom. That's it.
Keep it simple.
The generals under his command must be
in competent indeed if they do not know
how to execute this order and to
perform the proper maneuvers with their
respective divisions.
Thus the commander in chief will not
be forced to occupy with it nor be
embarrassed with the details.
For a fee temps to be a battle
sergeant and be everywhere himself.
He will resemble the fly in the fable
that thought he was driving the coach
with us on the day of the battle.
I should want the general to do nothing.
His observations will be better for it.
His judgment will be more sane and he
will be in a better state to profit from
the situations in which the enemy
finds himself during the engagement.
And when he sees an occasion,
he should unleashes energies,
hasten to the critical point at top
speed sees the first troops available,
advanced them rapidly,
and lead them in person.
These are the strokes that decide
battles or and gain victories.
The important thing is to see the
opportunity and know how to use it.
So what are you saying? There's
got to be detached. Hmm.
He's saying you got to be detached and
then you've got to stay back or you've
got to look around. Now he also says,
once you see the critical moment,
you've got to get up in
there and make it happen.
Okay?
But he's saying, you definitely
can't get laid down in the weeds.
You can't be the sergeant that's trying
to do everything back to the book.
Many commanding generals only spend
their time on the day of the battle and
making their troops march in a straight
line in seeing that they keep their
proper distances in answering questions,
which their aids the camp come to ask in
sending them hither and thither and in
running about incessantly themselves.
In short,
they try to do everything
and as a result do nothing.
So this is a great, this is just,
you're in a leadership position,
you try and do everything yourself.
You're not going to do anything at all.
Then it's the same. That's the same
thing as prioritized. Next, give me,
if you try and solve all the problems
that are happening at the same time,
you're not going to solve
any of those problems. Hmm.
Yeah.
They appear to me like men with their
heads turned who no longer see anything
and who are only able to do what
they have done all their lives,
which is to conduct troops methodically
under their orders up under the orders
of a commander.
How does this happen?
It is because very few men
occupy themselves with the
higher problems of war.
They pass their lives drilling troops,
and believe that this is the
only branch of the military act.
When they arrive at the command of armies,
they are totally ignorant and in
default of knowing what should be done,
they do what they know.
That is so classic. It's so
classic. When people don't know,
they don't understand something,
they do what they know how to do.
They they always default into
what they know how to do. Hmm.
Their minds are closed.
One of the branches of the art of war,
that is to say drill and the method of
fighting is the other is intellectual for
the conduct of the ladder,
it is essential that ordinary,
ordinary men should not be chosen.
Okay.
Unless a man is born
with a talent for war,
you will never be on other than a mediocre
general is the same with all talents
in painting or music or in poetry.
The talent must be
inherent for excellence.
All sublime arts are
alike in this respect.
That is why we see so few outstanding
men in science centuries past without
producing one application rectifies ideas,
but does not furnish us soul
for that as the work of nature.
You know,
I just answered a question on Twitter.
I think it was,
um, and I basically said, well, you know,
you can't do whatever you want.
Okay.
Just because you believe in it and you
have hard work and discipline like that,
that doesn't mean you can do whatever
you want like as a career or something.
Yeah. Like, and I always use the example
like I couldn't be on the Olympic,
let's say an Olympic weightlifter or the,
in fact,
I don't know that there's any
Olympic sport that I would
be, that I have the, um,
genetic makeup to be able to,
to be able to compete
at the Olympic level. I,
of course we could go back and
maybe that's possible from a child,
but I don't feel like it.
But even right now w you know,
if you take that to the extreme,
that means, hey, you know what?
If I have the focus and I have five,
the discipline,
I can become an Olympic wrestler now.
High Jumper,
Olympic high jumper, right.
How's that vert looking?
So you see what I'm
saying now my opinion is
that is not true.
And some people are not going to achieve
certain things that they may want to
achieve no matter how hard they
want to do it. And I, you know,
most people are like, yeah,
that's a realistic. Some
people were like, no, you can,
if you believe that you can achieve it.
It's like if I could believe it,
if I could achieve it because I believed
it, dude, I'd be like, I'd be, I'd be,
I'll just all winning.
Sure. Everything. Sure.
It's not that easy. Yeah, you got to
believe it. You got to work hard at it.
You got to have some natural capabilities.
So the way it is,
I'm sorry to let everyone down.
What was your line?
Is One of those lines that
you can kind of take with,
you said belief something odd.
Is it?
So you said it,
it belief is not going
to make anything happen,
but at the same time without
belief, nothing's going to
happen. Totally true. Yeah.
Yeah. So yeah, you've
got absolutely. So yes,
belief by itself won't make
anything happen that, you know,
some people sit around, I believe I
can do this, so I'm going to achieve,
no, no, no. You want to achieve,
you've got to do something. Yeah.
And the same token that is also correct
is that if you don't believe in what
you're doing, then yeah, there's
no way you're going to achieve it.
You won't be able to gut through
it when it gets problematic,
which it's certainly going to,
so sacs agrees with me that hey,
the work of nature, it has to be in
play. Otherwise it's not happening.
You might get to some
level, but yeah, reality is
the thought.
I think that's a hard one to admit you.
You don't seem like you want to admit
this. I think you're over there like you.
If you wanted to go the distance,
put it this way,
it seems really like that's not true.
It seems like you know,
you maybe you just didn't work hard
enough even though you thought that you
worked as hard as he possibly can and
maybe the fact that this is what it seems
like, but at the end of the day,
I do agree with that. I mean it's,
it's way clear with physical stuff.
Physical limitations are way
more obvious and there's, yeah,
there's, I don't know. Well,
let's face it.
Let's say playing guitar because I
play guitar and I also now kind of play
Ukulele. Yeah, but let's
say playing guitar,
even if you practice and you
can mechanically play guitar,
that doesn't give you the natural
spark of creativity that is demanded.
If it did,
then every person that worked hard and
play guitar would become a rock and roll
star with great creative songs,
but it just doesn't happen. Yeah.
There's hundreds of
thousands just in America.
There's hundreds of thousands
of people that play guitar.
At a incredibly capable proficiency.
Right? They can play every song
that you hear on the radio,
but you know what they do for
a living cover cover songs.
Will they play cover songs?
They're also working as a banker somewhere
because they didn't have whatever
creative thing that would give them to
be able to create something that was new
in that people want and
ruin and listen to that,
that needs to come from somewhere else
in practice isn't gonna get you there.
Some people learn it in the schools,
some people learn it on the streets,
but I think you kinda
gotta be born with it, man.
And that's a little
tenacious d for everyone.
Yeah. Yeah. And again,
like can you teach creativity?
And even then it's like,
yeah, but now, yeah, really.
Exactly. I mean, compared to the diagnosis
and then where do you get it really?
You know, it's uh, yeah,
it's weird. It's just,
I think that's really the reason that
it is true is because you can't put your
finger on it. You can't be
like, yeah, just work as hard
as you possibly can. Sure.
That's going to improve your other
classic example is look at the people.
You know what if I go to an academic,
a high level academic
environment where everyone is,
you know,
incredibly intelligent,
but not all of them are able
to do something that not all,
all of them are able to succeed
at the level that their,
that their heritage would point towards.
So just because you got a 1600 on your
sats and you did this and you went to
this great college,
there's a lot of people that did
all those things and they're,
they're not what they themselves
would consider a successful. Right.
And so the reality is there's
something not there. And like you said,
I don't know that you can actually put
your finger on it because there's some
other kid that didn't do any of that
and made stuff happen and was extremely
successful. There's thousands and
thousands of examples like that too.
So it's Kinda like when you compare it
like the proverbial person with all the
potential versus someone
with not that much potential.
And maybe the guy with the,
with Le less potential,
there'll be exceptions
where that guy made it.
And then there'll be obviously like all
these other scenarios where the guy with
the potential doesn't,
doesn't make it. So it's like,
all right know this guy's born with it.
What kind of,
let's take it to a new level, not
just making it, but actually being a,
the highest level for that person.
You got to have the talent
and you got to have the work.
You gotta do both tends
to be the case check.
And he says the same thing here.
I've seen very good colonels
become very bad generals.
I have known others who were
great takers of villages,
excellent for maneuvers within an
army, but who, outside of that,
we're not even able to lead a thousand
men in war who lost their heads
completely and now we're
unable to make a decision,
any decision. So he sees the
same thing. And, and you know,
I see that with business leaders,
the business leader
that you need to be the,
at the beginning of your business is not
the same business leader that you need
to be. Once your business is more
successful, you got to have this.
Some guys are good at street fighting,
right? They're good at street fighting.
They're not good at planning a war,
planning a campaign,
and so you might win as a company.
If you're a leader at the street
fighting level and you do good,
you scrap it out.
Then as you grow,
if you don't transition mentally and
become a different kind of leader,
not a different person,
but a different kind of leader,
you may not be able to
win at the higher levels.
So that needs to get paid attention to
back to the book one should once and for
all established establish a standard
combat procedures which the troops as well
as the general who leads them.
No,
I'm not the first person to talk about
standard operating procedures at all.
These are general rules such as preserving
proper distances on the march when
charging to charge vigorously to fill
up intervals in the first line from the
second no instructions
are required for this.
It is the a B,
c of the troops and nothing is
simpler standard operating procedures.
He also says that the general should
preserve an unfettered mind and not occupy
himself with trifles.
I am convinced that a skillful general
could make war all his life without being
forced into one.
That's the old,
the real martial artist doesn't have
to fight the art of fighting without
fighting.
This
war can be made without
leaving anything to chance.
And this has,
and this is the highest point of
perfection and skill as a general,
so he now are there things
that are left to chance in war?
Yeah, there's a lot of things
that are left to chance and warp,
but can you mitigate a lot
of those? Yeah, absolutely.
Back to book.
The words of the proverb,
a bridge of gold should be made for
the enemy is followed religiously.
Meaning I'm going to give,
if the enemy wants to run,
I'm going to build them a bridge. A goal
to run on. No, not you want to run away.
That's great. Warren
is over. This is false.
On the contrary,
the pursuit should be pushed to the
limit and the retreat which had appeared
such a satisfactory solution
will be turned into a route.
A detachment of 10,000 men can
destroy an army of 100,000 in flight.
Nothing inspires so much
terror or occasions.
So much damage for everything is lost.
So he's saying, no, you don't let the
enemy get away when they're running.
That's when you destroy them completely.
This is not to say that it is necessary
to give yourself up totally to the
pursuit and fall the enemy
with all your forces,
but if the officer you have ordered
in pursuit prides himself upon the
regularity of his formation and
the precautions of his march,
there is no use in having sent him.
He must attack,
push and pursue without cease.
All maneuvers are good,
then it is only precautions
that are worthless.
A yeah.
And that right there kind of wraps up
the highlights of this book attack,
Push,
pursue without ceasing.
And I believe that is also
known as getting after it. It.
What's interesting is I think it's
clear that as we continue to see these
leaders throughout history that we're
able to lead through the harshest of
conditions.
There's obviously a lot of common
principles that they share in.
So the question is, okay, why
do we keep breeding them? Hmm,
why do I keep trying to
confirm the same things?
Why am I always looking
actually for counterpoints
as well that offers some kind
of different solution?
Like the one about Sun Tzu today,
no need to be early on the battlefield.
If it's cold out there and it's going
to wear down your troops don't be early.
Hmm.
But from my perspective,
the more different angles
that you see these things,
the scene, the, the, the more different
ways that you learn the same lesson,
the more clearly you understand if you
learn an arm lock from three different
people, they're all going to
give you something different.
And it's the same thing.
We get something slightly different
from all these strategic thinkers.
Yeah.
And we get better understanding of it.
And there are differences
in what people say.
Okay.
And I think it's good to look at the way
those differences manifest themselves
on the battlefield and throughout history,
because maybe there's one solution that's
a little bit better than the one that
I know right now.
So for me,
I'm going to continually try to reinforce,
try and fortify,
try and stay humble as sacs talked about,
continue to learn and relearn
and discard what doesn't work.
And always try and get better.
Okay.
And I think that's all
I've got for tonight.
Yeah, I guess it better be. I thought
this was going to be a quick episode.
All good. All right. I guess we should
move quickly now. What do you think?
Do you agree with me or no, it doesn't
sound like it. We'll see what up.
So getting better.
Yeah.
Speaking of getting better duck wisdom
supplements, they're Jocko supplements.
We know you're going to get
better. And I, there's the case,
so Super Krill,
the Krill oil supplements,
good one super and joint
warfare and disciplined castle.
Let's say those three songs.
If anyone's wondering if you're watching
on youtube and you're seeing me drink
two things,
I'll drinking two things.
One of them is it a smart water bottle
and it is. I'm drinking discipline.
The other is in a Poland spring bottle
that I brought back from Maine to remind
me of Maine and I'm drinking
that one Jocko white tea.
So it was vital to be in
New York to put away, every,
all in the northeast will say,
yeah, yeah, but you won't get,
you won't find Poland spring out here.
No, no. That's when he brought
it back. Just don't nonetheless.
So the Super Krill Krill oil
better than fish oil factually,
factually.
And then there's Jocko Super Krill,
which is better than regular Krill oil
factually. And then there's, there's,
there's people out there not taking
Krill oil and I'm not saying they should
take real oil. They should take krill
oil. That's not what I'm saying right now.
I am saying if I will argue,
I'll actually
pretty much guarantee pretty much,
I know that defeats the
purpose of a guarantee,
but I'll pretty much guarantee that
if someone's not taking Krill oil,
whether you Jocko crew horror or not and
they take krill oil, there'll be like,
Dang, I should have started
taking this krill oil before.
Is it like learning Jiu Jitsu when
you started you just, you go man,
I should have said I wish I started this
when I was 13 it's just like that on a
smaller level,
on a joint maintenance level,
joint warfare is what I'm
feeling is for me that's kind of,
it's new. Right. You know and I'm like
man I wish I can get this for a long wait.
The joint warfare. Yeah,
cause you can feel,
it's like you're getting maintenance. Well
you should've came up with it earlier.
I know, I know. Next time
that's what you're going to do.
You can come up with it earlier. That's
what I think you should do nonetheless,
there for your joints.
It's a good and we're all working out.
They were making something.
We're making a new product,
we'll say sure.
And it is
okay.
It's going to be good. You're
going to like it. It's, it's a,
it's a protein drink and it's going to be,
oh it's, I've had, we've done two
samplings given the ingredient.
So we give the ingredients
to the supplement factory,
they mix them and we've gone through
to the F two we've gone through two
iterations.
The first iteration I was like,
oh my God, this tastes
good. Wait, wait, what?
Talking pure taste or taste? The
first one I was like all this, this,
this tastes good.
Really good.
Like the kind where you think this is a
whole new thing, you know what I mean?
Wait.
Yeah cause yeah cause protein,
tea tastes like protein
powders. That crap. Yeah.
And that was one of the things we research
to figure out how we could make it
taste legit. Good. Where you were not,
you're holding your nose enforcement down
between the first sample that we got,
which I was in Maine when we tasted it.
We stood there with me,
Brian and Pete and we were
standing there and we,
we all mixed it up together and import
it into three separate cups. Sure.
Anne and everyone, when we
drank it, everyone's like
quiet for a second. They did.
It was, oh my God, look what time is it?
Well this one was meant chocolate and,
and,
and it's just really good and obviously
the protein and is awesome and we've got
some other things in it that are
going to make it more complete.
But yeah. And then I just
got the sec, but you know,
there was a couple of adjustments
that I wanted to make to the taste.
Just the pure taste. Yeah. So
we just made those adjustments.
I got the second iteration and it
tastes even better than the first one,
but I still,
I've sent them back for one more,
but hopefully to only be one more
iteration before we can start producing.
It's going not going to
come out for awhile. Uh,
it takes a long time to get
everything rolling. But yeah. Anyways,
we have that in the future.
That's interesting cause I don't,
I'm not into protein powder.
You will be there is this one I'm telling
you you will be moved for protein.
It'll be for like a dessert. It'll be
like someone saying they're not into.
This is going to be like someone
saying I'm not into ice cream.
That's how tasty it is.
Good. I guess we'll see.
I guess that's kind of the test in a way.
In a way to test. Well good. Nonetheless.
Krill oil, joint warfare and
discipline. Those are already out. Yup.
Doing work discipline tastes good too.
That's another thing.
You don't have to drink something that
tastes like crap just because it's
awesome for you.
You can do something that tastes good
and I'll tell you one thing I've noticed,
and I don't know if this is,
I don't know what this means,
but when I drink discipline
cause I work out in the morning,
as I say all the time, I don't do a pre
workout thing. It's not my thing. Right.
I work, I work out in the morning on an
empty stomach and there was this old rock
climber and I can't think
of his name right now,
one of the famous old rock climbers.
And he would,
I read an article one time
about him where he was,
he would climb while starving himself
and wearing a weight belt who was harder.
And I was like, yeah, but if do
that, I've done that all the time.
Don't ever since anyways the D if
you have some discipline the drink,
then you will feel like,
so when I got done working out maybe like
let's say, you know, I always say, oh,
I usually have some nuts around mixed
nuts just to kind of get in my gut a
little food. I've been, I've
been having some some, you know,
a couple handfuls of mixed nuts and then
having some discipline and I still feel
so light. Super good that then
I'm just firing through the day.
And so basically what I'm getting at is
this is I've been eating even cleaner
because I'm eating like I'm
eating basically right now.
I think I'm eating a once a day meeting,
discipline, drink, it's discipline.
And then I'm going once a
day with a good solid meal.
And then yeah, it's man, it's good.
It's good stuff and that's good.
And that works for you. It was working
good for it because I'll tell you why.
When I eat less, I feel better.
And so this is making me eat less
now. I'm not saying now, believe me,
when I eat dude, I get it on. That's how
I roll. When I eat, I get it on. And,
but this is just,
yeah,
it's nice to be able to get
to feel energized and sharp
mentally without getting
crazy. Um, think that,
cause you know that idea that when
you eat less than you feel better.
And I found that to be the case
and this is what I realized.
I found that to be the case only
sometimes. And I was thinking,
why is it like that?
Sometimes if I'm doing something like,
you know when we go to the
muster or something like that,
I'll for sure FTX I were doing
something all day and I wasn't eating.
Yes,
but if you eat,
it's kind of like your body goes into
this like kind of wrestled for sure.
But if you eat a little bit or like just,
you know,
just like going to stand at all,
it's time to eat. Oh, could we,
could we cruising now you in your body,
you're basically telling yourself
you're going into level seven,
echo cruisey recruiters
technically recover mode.
It's really kind of what it does and
that's really what it felt like. So yeah,
I found that that, yeah. So you probably
have a bunch of stuff to do. Oh,
all the time. But when I'm
for sure, when you're like,
when I'm doing a fast, I want
to be doing something. Yeah.
You sit around and think about
food yet horrible. You feel like?
Like when Charlie plumb was talking
about being at the Hanoi Hilton and he's
just thinking,
they were just literally sitting around
thinking about food all the time because
there wasn't even anything to do.
Yeah.
And eating food is actually a little
bit of a cure or relief from boredom.
You're, you know how when you're a kid
you're just bored. You look in the fridge,
you're not hungry, you're
bored. Yeah, exactly.
It's funny because right now I got my, you
know my, it's wrestling season. So the,
the weight cuts are on and they're not,
neither one of my kids that are
resting are cutting a bunch of weight.
But it means that you don't,
you're,
it means that there's times when you
don't eat for a day right. Thing.
So you get to see the effects of that.
And my daughter's like, oh, I feel,
she's like, yeah, I feel fine. She's
just to get hangry or nothing. Yeah.
She doesn't get hangry. I
warned my wife, I said, hey,
you need to watch out cause
it won't people cause you
when you're cutting weight
with fighters they're cutting much more
severe weight and they start getting in
bad moods. Oh fighters. They start
getting in bad moods cause they can't eat.
They get hangry. Yeah but neither one
of my kids are cutting that much weight.
They're just kind of maintaining
through the season. Dude,
I dunno if we talked about hangry like
that's a for real thing because this is
what it is. When you, when you,
I mean Bilat physiologically your
frontal cortex or the prefrontal frontal,
I dunno,
whatever the front of your brain,
the part that's a
scientist makes decisions.
Oh an empathy and like all these things
get compromised one year when you're,
what hungry. I'll come
on man. Listen to me
because I believe that if you,
if if he made all those things less
effective than we wouldn't be here as a
species.
Cause every time we got hungry in the
past we would have gotten all confused and
frustrated and we are going
to be able to duck hunt.
But the bottom line is the opposite,
I think is true. Back in the dairy,
if needed a hunt something down,
you had to be sharp.
So when you didn't eat it made you sharper
and more attuned. That's how I feel.
Okay. That's not what, you know
what I read and heard, but hey,
I'm not saying that word that you can
go on the Internet and find an r two
scientific articles that
say the exact opposite.
Just follow me.
So hangry from what I read.
Correct. Well, they didn't use
the word hangry, but empathy.
And this is with like if you get
hungry or I'm sleep deprived,
whatever. Yeah, just a part of your brain
kind of. It doesn't shut down completely.
It just yesterday,
yesterday I went to sleep.
I went to bed.
Sure.
Eight 30 at night. Hey, yeah,
I woke up at like three 50
and I was Kinda, I was like,
Dang, that felt good. Yeah,
I was, but I didn't sleep almost at all
the night before. So I was recovering.
I needed to put some more back in the
bank. And everyone says you can't do that.
You can't catch up on sleep. I just
did it. Yeah. I don't know. Just did
I caught up on sleep. I never let your
finisher, your scientific explanation.
So what was the deal?
It just pre frontal cortex or whatever
the um, so you know, you'll treat
people were technically, um,
so yeah, hangry. That's apparently
roof from what I read is, is it an actual
thing? Maybe not. So maybe I'm sure.
Aggression, aggression, maybe it does
make you sharpen when you're sharper,
you're not taking any crap from anybody,
so you're more aggressive towards them
because you want to go out and hunt and
kill something. Maybe. I do
agree with you. Weird Science.
Say Tomato. I say tomato.
You know, you'd be
aggressive, but nonetheless,
um, yeah, it's a real
thing apparently. Okay.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Not to say that everyone's going
to behave in a certain way.
I'm just saying that's what
happens internally. Maybe.
Maybe not nonetheless get disciplined.
It'll cognitively enhance lift your
prefrontal or frontal cortex. I forget.
We just,
both of them both though
Acre frontal thing in your
brain is shutting down. Boom.
Take that discipline. The cognitive
enhancers is going to help it out a lot.
Don't be hangry even if you're hungry.
Guess where you can get
these things@originmean.com
it's a lot of cool stuff on
there or Jen Maine also has geese.
Yeah,
rash guards, various clothing items all
made in America. That's a good spot.
Just check it out. Look on there.
It's a lot of cool stuff on there.
If you want something,
get something. Also,
if you're into workout equipment
to populate your home gym,
it's good having a home gym. By the way.
One of my friends is coming into town
and he's like, yeah, let's
catch a workout. I'm like,
we don't have to go to
a gym and catch work.
I work at at home to do something else.
Nonetheless,
it made me think of how good it is
to have a home gym. Nonetheless,
if you have your home gym,
you want to populate it even a little bit.
Get your workout stuff from on it.
That's what I think it's the cool one.
You can do various interesting
workout routines with the equipment.
Unlike Jocko Jocko,
his workouts are super boring.
Even though you do have kettle bells,
which I respect. Yeah, and anything you
want to add on that? No Man, that's it.
Are you sure if that was the workout?
The kettlebell, you're good, you're good,
you're solid and I'm sure you're getting
very strong and I'm sure you know in
case everyone doesn't know
and and running his mouth,
and I use that term like with,
I'm not just throwing it out there are
really was running my mouth and you're
really pissed off that you have a what?
How much is your heaviest? Kettlebells?
90 90 95 foot boom.
And my heaviest kettle bell was 88 pounds.
This is no longer a problem. Now
my heaviest kettle bells, plural,
because I have to do is 48 kilograms or
106 pounds commonly referred to as the
beast.
So nonetheless minor from audit.
They're the cool ones.
And you can get other cool exercise stuff.
They're still go on it.com/jocko
check all this stuff there.
Do you want to get something?
Also,
when you get your copy of reveries
on the art of war by Maurice,
it's a good one. I like those manual
kind ones. You know the one that goes,
I know is,
if you think about it,
there's really three types of
podcasts that are happening.
One is a to is manual
strategies about war.
Three is human nature inside war.
So those are kind of, when I'm
reading a book I'm like, Oh yeah,
I just kind of like one
of those. Yeah. Yeah.
So this would be with Napoleon's
maxims or something like that.
The Art of war by Sun Tzu.
So we've done quite a number of
books like that and you know,
I get a little something different from
each of them because if you think about
it, he says that you have to pay
attention to the human heart. Well,
where are you going to
learn about the human heart?
And he didn't say much about it. As much
as he said you need to know about it.
He didn't say much about it.
Where are you going to find it?
You're gonna find it by reading people
that were actually in war and start to
understand where their heart
was in this whole gig. Yeah.
It's interesting too because they're
laid out in these specific contexts,
you know, like, um, like Sun Tzu that
he's, he's talking about, you know,
a certain time period,
a certain place,
and then Vietnam one and then
a world war and they're still,
they're talking about,
okay,
these principles at this time
and this is why they work well,
it was interesting to do I drang and
how more because it was his battle to
podcasts on his battle and then his
book that he wrote about leadership.
So you kinda got to see maybe,
I don't know,
I don't know if there's anything now
we've seen some of that when for instance,
you got Napoleon's maxims,
right?
And then we got to hear from
a Napoleonic foot soldier.
So you get to kind of see, see
the, what the world was like,
what the human heart was,
was going on with the human heart,
and then what was going on with the minds
of the stratus Titian or even know if
that's a word. It's tragic.
Sure. I think so. Just be kicked.
You know what's cool is the
English language, you can
words vague, vague, vague.
They come about, you just get
formed. Yeah. That's a catch.
There's a time where there was no
word and that word is there yet.
If you look at the OED,
which is the Oxford English dictionary,
it tells you where the f w,
w word came from and then
it has like first usages.
So there's some words.
This word is this for this word was first
in print in 1622 in this work of art
or this work of literature.
Yeah. It's crazy to like words.
We'll go in these cycles where
there'll be used like eight, right?
If you say ain't, that's a
game. That's an improper thing.
It's not really a word level by ain't was
actually used by like high upper class
people back in the day,
like long time ago and like ain't and
Shan't and all these like words like I
Shit, you know, all this.
And eight was one of them.
There's one home and I forget the deal,
but someone in the lower class
started using it and they're like, oh,
they're using it now, or
something like that. So it
went out and now it's like, oh,
that's not a word that it is a word,
the ink, the language in general.
But definitely the English language.
I studied English in college and,
but the,
the classes that I took,
some of the classes that I took where I
would focus on that, which was pretty,
which is always very interesting to me.
Very interesting to me.
And I think the reasons it's interesting
to me is because language is how we
communicate.
Communication is how we lead.
So if you don't know what words you're
using or you can't find the right word to
articulate what it is
you're trying to say,
you're gonna have a harder time
getting your message across.
When you have a harder time
getting your message across,
it's harder for you to lead. Yeah. So,
and then if you kind of look
at the big picture of that,
it's kind of like you have been,
then you kind of in a way should know
slang and stuff like that. For sure,
for sure is if you're over here talking
to quote unquote all proper to people
who aren't used to hearing sure property,
they can be like,
what's this guy talking about? Or
whatever. That is definitely true.
And it's not just about language
there, it's about culture as well. And,
and you know, one of the cool things
that when I grew up and I was kind of,
you know, getting into the heart and
I was in the hardcore scene, right?
It exposed me to people and things
that I wouldn't have seen if I would've
stayed in my small, New England
town. So when I got to the world,
meaning got out of that small town
in an hour, I was in the military,
I was able to understand better
than I would have if I didn't.
Yeah. And I think that's important.
Yeah. Yeah, it helps for sure. You have,
okay. How's this word?
Irregardless. Right ear regardless.
It's not even a word, right. That's
what they said. So I had this bet,
this is a long time.
It was like over 10 years ago.
I just bet cause coworker of mine and I,
for whatever,
I think my dad taught me like, you're
a girl, this is not a work, you know,
and he'd always like correct to you so
you don't have any imprints in your mind.
Like someone uses the word irreguardless,
they should be corrected.
That was kind of imprinted in my
subconscious. So it happened at work,
Charles Grammar Nazis for a little
bit. It was more just, that was fun.
But nonetheless, he,
um, no, she was a girl,
I said in regardless and word
and she was like, yeah, it is.
I was like, no, Irregardless
is like a misuse, misuse of
a word. Is that regardless,
regardless, Irregardless is a misuse of
war. It's not a word. She was like, well,
if it's a, if it's a word,
if it's a misuse of a word,
it's the word for the misuse of
this specific word. And I'm like,
it's not a word that hell did
that just mean she's saying.
She's saying basically if you can say
it and you can spell it and it's like if
it's a little name for something,
it's not the name of anything.
Name for a misuse of a word is what?
That was her argument. That's what I,
that's what I was saying.
Did you win money? No, I did
not win the myself money. No.
So we're, we, it never got resolved
between me and her. We hated it.
I think we kind of hated each other.
I would cause it got heated.
We actually didn't hate each other.
It was cool. But nonetheless,
that was her stance.
My stance is you can't just invent a word.
You can't just use a word wrong,
invent another word because you're wrong.
And then be like, oh, now
it's a word, now I'm right.
All of a sudden you can't do
this. Not how it works. And then,
so I look it up in the dictionary. Yeah.
It was haunting me. So when I went over,
I looked it up in the diction.
Sure enough,
the thing was there and
it said the misuse of the,
or the common misuse of regardless.
So I'm, but I'm still confused.
Like is that a word? And here's the
thing, I talked to Jane about it. Yeah.
It bothered me a lot. Yeah. So I talked
to jade about it and he was like, Bro,
that's kind of how the language is
getting enough people misusing regardless,
saying Eric Irregardless list,
boom.
All of a sudden he gets shuffled right
into the rotation as a legitimate words.
What is that a good thing or is that
a bad day? It's a beautiful thing.
It's a beautiful thing.
It is.
Language is always evolving and that's
what allows the language. Just like,
just like Jujitsu, just like a mixed
martial arts. You want it to evolve.
You want it to new words to come out that
can articulate something a little bit
better. He's like, for instance,
it regardless articulates its,
you don't have the English
language very well, but, but yeah,
at some point a hundred
years in the future,
regardless will become a word that has
a little bit of a different meaning than
regardless.
Like it's maybe it's more regardless ear,
regardless of what you're saying.
And it will say first used in the,
you know,
somebody is gonna write an article
in online or, and it's going to,
the guy's going to misuse it,
but everyone's gonna understand it and
it's gonna say first used here. Yeah.
There's all kinds of arguments
you can have about language,
but you have to remember that
it's evolving all the time.
Our languages are evolving all
the time and it should, in France,
they try not to let their language evolve.
Yeah.
The try and keep that
language since you're seeing,
or the ultimate result is something
like that would be the word.
I think it's the same result.
If you try and not not
evolve your martial arts,
eventually, if you don't evolve your
martial arts, you're going to lose.
It's the same thing with language.
Yeah.
You become less effective communication
with in language as far as that goes.
The word literally now. Okay.
Literally, we know at Lahey,
here's the hard part about accepting this,
because literally means something very
specific. There's no ambiguousness.
If it started to be ambiguous,
you wouldn't say literally,
say figuratively or are, you just won't
say anything. That's what I did. That's,
that's the defining characteristic of the
word, literally. But here's the thing.
Now literally doesn't mean literally,
literally means just re almost a
lot. Oh yeah. Just really strong.
Not even, almost literally. It's just
really strong. So if I was like, man,
this guy joke was so funny.
I was literally dying, right?
I wasn't almost dying
is not what it means.
It just means it was super
duper duper funny. You know
what's changing? Yeah, man,
that's a hard one to accept. Like and
all. I think there's another word,
but in America, in California,
this is a recent one,
so maybe the 80 [inaudible]
everyone's to in order to say said,
said like, or all echo was
like, you gotta stop doing this.
And I was all no way
we're going to do that.
And that's just the way the language
of orals. Dang. That's cool. Hey Man,
I dig it.
It's all nonetheless fifth,
you want to buy this book regardless,
regardless of the language in it.
It don't do that.
What I did was I made it easy. You got
to Jocko podcast.com on the top menu,
whenever you put a page there,
has all the books by episode.
This one is on there along with
everything else. Just click through there.
It's a good way to support and you get,
you'd takes you to Amazon and
you get your book in eight hours,
however long it takes to ship to
your house. Good way to support.
Also if you're doing other shopping,
if you're going to buy that lawnmower
and leaf blower that you've been meaning
to buy.
Okay.
And the Reiki as well. Um, false.
I'm just saying you're in the wrong time
zone ever. Wrong time of year for that.
Wait, the rake? No,
it's about to be spring,
so you got another six months before you
need to get the rain gout and the lawn
blower. Yeah. That's one of the last
things that I bought the leaf blower.
Really? Yeah. Okay.
Long story nonetheless.
Duct tape. That's year round thing.
Duct tape and just carry on shopping.
Whatever you want to do. That's it.
That's what you do. Good way to spark.
Also subscribe to the podcast, iTunes,
stitcher, Google play, Spotify.
We're wherever else.
They have a podcast and the wherever
else you and listen to the podcast.
They have like new podcasts apps out
to, yeah, they all have them. Yeah,
and I dig it. So Hey, whatever you're
using to listen, so that's correct.
It's a good one. Seems obvious,
I guess on the listening part,
but youtube not so much. We have a
youtube channel. Subscribe to that too.
That's a good way to support if you want,
because some people not into youtube
who's gone into youtube, I don't know.
But you can also waste a bunch
of time on it. Yeah, yeah.
It's like just it's, yeah, it's like
the Internet in general. You know,
a lot of good stuff like your whole like
pursuit can be on the Internet and it
can be very beneficial at the same time.
Your whole pursuit can be in the internet
or you do, and it can be detriment.
Do you mean your pursuit? Like,
well, whatever you're trying to do,
going on the Internet, we'll
will basically make it so
like if you're trying to,
if you're trying to learn three
d modeling, go on the Internet,
you can learn three d modeling,
100% well not 100% but you can learn to
be a professional three d modeler on the
internet at the same time.
You get caught up watching some nonsense
and not even take one step towards
three d modeling. I spent what I'm saying,
it's the dichotomy of the Internet.
Youtube has the same dichotomy,
but if you subscribe to the Jocko podcast,
youtube channel, there's no
dichotomy there. All good. All good.
I don't have to send upside because it
has video version of the podcast is has
excerpts and it has various other
little videos. We'll just sort of add.
I always say I'm going to add,
but this time I think I'm really an ad,
a different type of video. You'll see.
Let be good. Anyway, good way to support.
Also, Jack was a store, if
you didn't already know,
it's called Jacqueline store,
drugstore.com that's where you can get
the shirt that Jack was wearing right now.
Victory, MMA and fitness. You don't
even have to be a member of Vic Victor,
MMA in fitness. You if you have the
shirt, you're kind of a member. Yeah.
At least in spirit. You're a member
in, in w, yeah, in that sort of way.
Nonetheless,
it's on [inaudible] dot com is where you
can get any of the shirts that we make
and so we also have hoodies on there
and rash guards and hats and patches.
Let a good stuff. Kids, women's good
stuff. I'm not saying to go buy something.
I'm not saying that. I'm saying go
there. drugstore.com check out the stuff.
You want something,
get something and that's a good way
to support also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
which I know you do,
but in the unlikely event of
you not knowing what that is,
this is what it is. It's an
album, not a music album.
It's a spoken word album with tracks Jocko
helping us through weak points of our
day. We points of our
campaign against weakness,
weak points of our struggle.
Struggle,
good struggles. Struggle for good. Sure.
Struggle for good. That's what it is.
You know the day you want to,
you want to sleep in or you want to
cheat on the day, you
want to procrastinate, you
want to skip the workout.
That's the main one. That's
iconic one, skipping the workout.
Oh the rest of us are over here getting
leg day. I did legs the other day.
A good one. Didn't skip it. Psychological
warfare it. That's on iTunes.
It helps you through it. Yeah.
Some people they don't know,
so it's a Jocko on each track. Proud. I'm
telling you sometimes they like, wait,
what did,
I didn't hear the of this psychological
or they're not going to listen to the
rest of this podcast, but they will.
It only has like two minutes, three,
four like top 25 minutes left.
I'm just saying it's like
psychological warfare is good.
If you want Jocko to
help you just put it in.
That's how it originated me.
Not Skip workouts and get it on iTunes.
You can get on Amazon music.
You can get on Google play
and other podcasting, MP3
platforms providing platforms.
Also, if you're on Amazon, you can
get something called Jocko white tea.
If you don't want to have your dead lift
increased to a minimum of 8,000 pounds,
then don't get Jocko white tea.
You can get the books. Yeah.
The books that we covered on the podcast,
which are all listed on the website,
you can also get a couple of books
that you might want to check out.
One of them is called way of the war.
Your kid. I actually wrote that book,
teaches kids
to make their lives better,
to get on the path and work hard.
There's another book coming out. It's
actually available on Amazon right now.
Well, you can't get it yet,
but you can preorder it.
If you want to spread the
word, you preordered it. That
makes more people see it.
So that's cool. It's called way
of the warrior kid Mark's mission.
Nice little follow up to
weigh the warrior kid.
Different lessons to be learned
so you can check that off.
Do you want to check out
an actual warrior kid?
You can go and get some
Jockos soap from young Aden,
12 years old. No big deal.
You know what he's doing?
Making soap has his own business.
You can get that@irishoaksranch.com.
Like I said,
a 12 year old kid making goat
milk soap. You know why? You know,
why did that?
You can't sell goat milk in California,
but you can't sell goat soap
milk. So yeah, for sure.
So he wanted to make some good ones
so you can check that out as well.
The discipline equals freedom field
manual. It's about getting after it.
There's really nothing
more to say. Hmm. If you,
I've gotten a lot of great feedback from
that book so I appreciate it and once
you feel that you've gotten
what you can out of it,
loaned it to somebody so they can get on
the path to maybe they'll get their own
or get it for them,
whatever. It's your choice.
Important part of that. Everyone
wants the audio version of that book.
The discipline equals freedom
field manual is not on audible,
it's on iTunes, Amazon music, Google play,
other MP3 platforms.
And it also is an album that has tracks
the, some people say with tracks,
extreme ownership.
The new edition is out.
Thank you for helping us put the new
to new edition together cause we've got
questions from this podcast,
a new Ford,
but we've also got pictures or questioned
from the podcast in their extreme
ownership,
combat leadership,
how to get out there and [inaudible]
and a win for on site leadership
instruction and consulting.
You can bring our company Ashkelon
Front to your organization.
We solve problems through leadership.
Simple as that. You've got a problem.
The way you get the problem solved
is through leadership. It's me,
it's Leif Babin.
It's JP to know Dave Burke.
Email info national on front.com or
you can go through the website echelon
front.com there's also the muster
leadership seminar with the Echelon Front
team.
We're only doing two this year.
I'm going to try and get a bunch of
questions that I get asked all the time.
I'm going to try and get
rid of those questions.
Right now we're only doing
two musters this year.
We aren't going to New York City.
We aren't going to Texas.
We aren't going to Florida. We aren't
going to your hometown. I'm sorry.
We just can't. We can't go to every
town in America to do a monster.
We're only doing two of them this year.
We're doing one
in Washington DC, so there's an
east coast and the west coast.
One is in Washington DC.
It's May 17th and 18th we're doing
another one in San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th so if
you want to come to a monster,
you got to come to one of those two.
We're not going to Omaha,
we're not going to Milwaukee.
I want to go there,
but unfortunately we can't just
get to all those different places.
So apologize.
Thus far there has been for monsters
that we've done over the past,
a year and a half,
they all sold out.
These two monsters are
going to sell out as well.
So if you want to come and you want to
learn pragmatic leadership skills and
strategies,
then you can go to extreme
ownership.com and you can register.
We will see you there.
Echo Charles will also be there
and until you get to the monster,
if you have questions for us
or you have answers for us,
we're looking for both.
We're here and we are cruising
hard actually on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
Instagram and on Daffy Echo is at
echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally thanks to those people out
there that make this podcast possible.
And by that I mean first and
foremost our military men,
women who
go into harm's way to protect
our freedom and our way of life.
Thanks to you and also to the police
out there holding the thin blue line.
Thanks for protecting us here on the home
front to the firefighters, paramedics,
and other first responders.
Thanks for being ready to come out
and rescue us anytime day or night.
And to everyone else that is listening.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for sharing.
Thank you for supporting the podcast
because we appreciate, we appreciate
all that, but more important.
We appreciate going down
this path with all of you.
So keep putting one foot in front of
the other as you move down this path.
Keep making the decisions,
the right decisions,
even on the little things.
Keep attacking,
pushing,
pursuing without cece.
And most of all,
keep getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.